do you have a react interview coming up
do you just want to test your react
skills
this course is for you
in this course nishant singh from
cybernetico will teach you how to answer
the most common react interview
questions and if you know any other
common react questions leave them in the
comments to help other learners
hello
i am nishant and welcome to my video on
which you will learn about react
important concepts and interview
questions
provided by free code camp
here we learned mostly about all the
important concepts in react that are
widely used
in production and in development
and also which are asked in an interview
so let's get started now
to use the map and filter we will
display all the data from the api coming
to this here from which api we will
display all the data in this ui at the
place of this one card which
is returning my name and username
fine
so initially we are getting the data in
the response in the console
let me show you what i mean
open the console
let me have this
let me show you this we are getting all
this data here
so first step is
first step to do this here is to create
a variable
and in react
variables are simply called states
so
i mean we call them states because they
can change the property so let me create
a state or variable called users which
is a variable name
and to set the data we will have this
set users
function
and in this use state we will have to
use an array because all the data is in
an array
see followed by objects
so let me store them here
save this and let me just
now use the map
so to use the map function we will just
we can just use
first the array name which is called
users
users dot map
then it takes a parameter called user
and
from this parameter we have to return
the html
wait something is yes now fine
which is called we have to turn some
html called div or anything you want
yes
so see here we have the data like id
name username email address all the data
so this name username email they are
called keys
so to show the keys
sorry so the values which are this
lingaram
bread
all the data
we have to use
the value so to through the value we
will just use user
dot name
but let me copy this
card inner and paste it here
then in the p tag i will just say
user dot name
and here we will just we will say
user
dot username
username
let me see the correct key this is small
username find save
and see all the data is now being
displayed here from this api
so this name is called the key and the
lien graham and bit is called the value
now
because the object exists in key value
pairs
all right so that's how map works
now let me give you another example
of what we can do with map
let me create a function here say
map data
data
it's done it's a function
then
let's just multiply the id with two
because it's a number
so how to do that we will just first use
the users first let me create one more
array called
let's say mapped array
so in this array so i mean this
this map
if you are mapping any array it will
return a new array not the previous one
because it's transformed
so let's say we want to multiply the
users by two
i mean the user id
so we can do this
user
then we can say user dot id multiplied
by two
now in this area of mapped array
all the ids will be multiplied by 2 so
we will get
2
then 2 into 4 then 6
and 4 into it and so on
let me console.log
this
mapped array
let me create a function to trigger this
so i need a function to but a button yes
you see c
map
array
so just assign the function to this
button
using on click event now if we click
click this button
it will
run so let me remove this two first
i think we don't need any other thing
just this
but let me leave it
let me add the button outside
here for your difference
let me add it here
fine
if we click this button
all the mapped array will be shown in
the console
all the items multiplied by two let me
get it to bottom
how to add it yes
here
click mapped array cmap ready
and see
on the line number 20 online number 14
we are seeing all the mapped array
multiplied memory ids
multiplied by 2 like 2 4 6 8 and all so
so that's how map works
now let me show you how filter works
so first of all
let's say
okay wait let me remove this
save this
let's say we want
to see only those name
whose name was first let's start from a
so how do we do that we will filter the
data
from this users array
so we will say let
filtered data
equals to use state
and then we will add an empty array
no wait what i'm doing
it's wrong
i am lost today
yes so you will do users dot filter to
filter data
and same like the map it takes an user
parameter
then we will have to return something
like this
we will say
return
user dot wait sorry sorry
user whatever
user
dot name
equal to leanne graham
so let me just control this now
to check if we're right or not
open the console
click see mapped array
we have an array here
of
only one item
because
the
condition is we are only filling the
name
of the user which has the name of leon
graham
if we make an a here it will fetch all
the data
of the names starting from a
now starting from not from a we will
fetch all the data which has the
username of a
i think we will get an empty array
c because none of the items have none of
the names
have a name name of a just a
to check if all the items include a
letter a we can do this
return user
return user.name
to lower case includes
our a
this
now let's try
refresh
into lowercase
okay we don't need this
point
now let's try see mapped array
we are selling an empty
because
none of the i okay i think none of the
items have a big a
all of them are having a small a
yes so make it a small a
then we will see
all the items with a in them
which have which are having seven items
we have seven items
so this and this and this
so that's how it works
we can also do
other properties
like
this
so we can say
user
dot id
if it is less than
five
we will see only them
so if the user not id is less than five
so we will see
one to four let me check now
see mapped array
and we are having only four data one two
three and four
if you want to see the fifth data from
one to five we will have to make
condition like this if returned
user id is
less than or equal to five
now let's check
c we now get all the data
okay so this map and filter can work
together also
so let's say we filtered the data with
all the items less than five all the ids
less than five
i mean less than equal to five so let's
map them now in an array
so how to do that
we can simply set this set users
then
filter data
let me remove
the data from here okay leave it leave
it
we have certain data here first then
we're filtering it if the user id is
less than five or equal to five
then let's check
we having one two three four five ten
items if we click the button this will
be changed to five
one two three four five or lean gram
this
this
this and this
click the mapped array
and see the error has now been filtered
to only five items
if we make it
more than or equal to five
let's see what happens we will see
last five items
like from mr miss dennis
screw list see mapped array
okay yes we are seeing six items
we have to remove
equal to
now let's try again
see
we are saying the last five items here
okay so
that's done
okay now let me give you a simple
example very simple example
we will combine these two first
i mean we will combine map and
filter together so we will say let sorry
const let's say
numbers
and set numbers let me have the numbers
from 1 to 10
1 2 3 4 5 6
7
37
8
9
and let me also add 10
let me add them fine
so here let me just comment it first
here
and then we will do it here
so first let me console or let me just
map these numbers here
so
to map the numbers we can simply do the
thing like we did previously
but this time
we don't have the objects we have this
just an array of 10 numbers
so how do we show that
so we can say
this number dot map we will return the
number
and we can simply say diff dot give a
number but we have a problem we need one
small bracket also
and all the numbers are here
let me add the class name of card here
save and this one card enter
here
we have all the numbers one to ten let
me comment out this card this card
and make this as
numbers
from one to ten
so we have one to ten numbers in this
array here
of numbers
now let me transform this array using
map
so first we will create an
uh let variable which will be called
square
root
point
then i will simply map the numbers
to get this square root square it's not
square root sorry
fine so numbers dot map we will use map
function just like before and it will
take a number param
so this number is all the numbers like 1
2
3 to 10 like 1 to 10
it will take a number param
which is 1 to 10 and it will multiply
each number 1 to 10
as we want
let's say in this function we having a
square then it will return
number into number that is mainly my
that mainly becomes the square root
we can console.log
this number here
sorry now number square
let's check the console now
we have an area of fire i think i need
to refresh the page
no not refresh we have to click this
button
click it
and we have the square of all the items
inside like 1 4 9 16 and all
fine that's done
so here we can have two cases
so in this console we are seeing all the
numbers from 1 to 800
which are square of all the items
so let's say we want the filter
first let's say we want to filter
or make the square root of one of those
number which are less than five
so how do we do that so let me remove
and show you from the start it will
select
let's num let number
less
than
5 equal so i will say number let me turn
off this github copilot
disable for java globally fine you can
say number
or numbers what is it
yes it's numbers
dot filter first we have filter them
first
it will take up when i am called number
i mean all the numbers just like before
then we will return
this
we will return all the numbers we want
which are less than or equal to 5
it will return all the number numbers
number this number we want here
it will return all the numbers less than
5
then
if this function closes the filter
function here
we can say map
then we want to store all the data in an
array
in this slit numbers array
so we can say
let's say
mapped or filtered numbers
say filtered
fill
third
third
yes spelling is now correct
then again it will return us something
it will return us
all the data
which is
wait i am doing it wrong like this it
will return something so they can say
return
what do we need to return
the filtered
fine
now let me store this number less than
five in the set numbers array
set numbers we are having yes
less than
we have to set this here now yes
like it
now we are seeing all the numbers from
one to five
but now if we click the button
it will first
fill all the numbers less than five or
equal to five
then it will make a square root also yes
we need this
filtered into filtered to get the square
root
save
let's try click the mapped array same
amd button see we are seeing all the
items less than or equal to five
so we are saying five six
not
not more than less than yes sorry
less than five we want refresh the page
the mapped array
now we're seeing all the numbers
which are less than 5
and the square roots so we have 1 so
it's 1 we have 2 so it's 4
3 9
4 16 525
fine
so that's how we do it
how map and filter works together so we
have filter and then map
now let's see to reverse the conditions
of functions i mean
so first we will do this so first we
will list all the items all the square
roots and then we will map or then we
will filter them so let's say remove the
filter here first
here we will save all the square squares
of all the numbers
click the button
and all the numbers have now been square
squared so 1 is 1
2 is 4 3 9 16 and so on
but now we want to see all the numbers
which are less than 50
so we will get till
49
so we can do this
so number less than 5
here we will add
filter
then we will say
it will take a it will take a parameter
called let's say
number again
then it will return something like
uh wait like this return
you can say number
less than five
or maybe equal to
fine save
now click the button
okay not five
50. sorry 50 yes
now you will see
all the numbers squared
and then fill that
on the condition that if it is less than
50 we will show it here
see mapped array
okay we only see two
which are less than 50.
wait something is wrong here
refresh page see mapped array now it's
fine
we are seeing all the numbers less than
50 after mapping
so on the previous case we were
filtering before
and mapping after that
but in this case we are mapping it first
and then we're filtering
so that's how map and filter works
together in both cases
so that's all now
i hope you learned how map and filter
works
in javascript and react
here i have a simple example with a
count variable let count equal to zero
one function to increment it
one h one tag and return to display the
count value
and one button to increment the count
when we click it
so let's try this example
click the button
see every time you click the button
increment the count
the value is getting increased by 1 1 2
three four and five
but our page is not getting updated this
zero is still zero
that is because when this count changes
in this
function
it's not rendering our component this
app.js component to solve this we have
stated react
so to create a state in the functional
component we will have react hooks we
have react hooks
so our hook is called uninstead
we have to import it first like this
import use state from react
so we have to create a state first
so const
arrow brackets sorry uh what is it
array brackets
so array
we will have the value variable name
which is count
and one function to change it when we
want to change
so we will have to use set count
you can use anything you want
at the place of set count
then
followed by as you use state
in this small bracket we will add the
type of the state
so it's a number because it's zero one
two three
so we'll use zero like this
let me remove this count fine
so that's done so if we save the file
this count will be 0
because now the count is coming from
here
if we change it to 1 they should this
will be one
see so let's make it zero
now to change it
we have to do this we don't need to use
we don't have to use this
so to change it we will just use set
count
and in the set count we will increase
the value of count like this
or let me modify this existing existing
one
so
remove this stream of this count equal
to countless one we will simply set
the value let's say the count is getting
incremented by one
then we will save the value
in the set count
now let's try
let's increment the count
see now it's getting incremented
properly
like this
fine
so that's how we use states in react
you can create any type of state you
want like
this is a number then we can have a
string let's say name
let's say set name
equals to use state
let me use the so this is our num name i
mean it's a string
so we'll use
quotes
fine
then we can have other states like
boolean let's say
is visible
and
set it we will have
set
is which set
is
visible
the new state so it's a boolean
so
let's say we want to make it false
initially then we have to use false here
fine
let me give an example here of this
boolean state
let's say we have a button or this
button
we want to see this button only when
the state sits the state is true
so we'll use curly brackets
so is visible if it is true
i am using the ternary operator
so if it is true
then this first and small bracket will
run or anything inside it
it will return this
this button but else if it is not
okay let me just make it some
h1 tag here and
i will say
visible
and if it is not true we will say
not
visible save
so now let's change it
remove this or just after this
we can have set it set is visible
we will reverse the value using this
thing
so you can say
not equal to
is visible
so let's say if it is false
so if we click the button or this
function will run
it will be reverse false which is true
then it's getting stored inside the set
set is visible
let's try we have not visible
click the button to run the function
see now it's visible
click it again
this would be invisible or not visible
see
that's how it works
to use set name we can also use set name
so let's say we want to set the name to
nishant
let me print it out here as well
in h1
so see initially it's nothing so we have
not seen anything here
click the button given the count
or let me change the name of this button
you can have
change states
much proper
click
now see the name is now here
fine
we can have array states as well and
object sheets so we can say const let's
say array
and set array
use state to use array state we will
have to use
this because this denotes an array we
can have multiple objects inside array
or multiple items like this
or if we want objects we have to use
this so let me create
or just do this an object first
let's say name
which would be equal to nishant
let's say age
26
let me create one more object in this
array
to make this an array object array
object
sorry object in an array yes that's
called any object
so
here we have to use name as something
else like uday
and make 25 or 26
fine
so it's an added state
see
we can also have an object state here
we can say const
object and
that object
impulse to use state
let's say
an object
if you want to make it empty it will be
empty like this but if you want to add
some value initially we can add some
things like name and h properties like
this
so this is the numeric state this is the
string state boolean state array state
and
object state
so that's how
state works and react i mean
mostly in
functional component
let's now change to class components
so use the class components let me let
me just remove all this and make rcc
class component
to make the class component state let me
just remove this as well fine
we have to use something called
constructor first constructor
i think that's right
inside this we have to use super keyword
then we need the state to create the
state we have to use this keyword
this dot state
equals to let's say a name
so name could be empty state
or we can have default state like
nissans
fine so that's how we create in the last
component
let me print the state here
so to print the state we will have to
use
this dot state dot name
but let me wrap it in h1 tag
h1
save
see the name is here okay
let me add class name of
fine
this should be in center
it's not
let me okay
need to import android css
import
app not css
like this now it's in the center
so if you want multiple states we have
to use name
then we can use let's say
age
we can have 0 initially
or null also but we don't use i don't
prefer to use null
so to add the age state we can use age
it's zero
fine
similarly in use state we have this
state
let's say we have an array of something
let's say an array
and just a colon
and the
array we can have one two three four
five
six like this
so to
view this we can just say
this
dot array dot
map
body this dot state dot error dot map
desktop state dot
array dot map
to get the values from this array
see
so we have to use
one
property
so if you want to see how map works you
can see my previous video in the same
playlist
so we can say
item
so
this map okay i will not explain this to
you
but basically
this map will increment or it map this
map will
what is it called
iterate over every item and do something
so let's say we want to return something
like this return
let's say item multiplied by 2
save
see the all the data is now here
i mean all the array items so
one is multiplied by two then four then
like this
so that's
an added state
let me remove this
all right
so
let me
show you how to change the state
so we can never vary a function say
change okay here we don't use const
keyword sorry
we just use change state
it's been so long since i used class
component
fine chain state
let me add a button
button
let's make it as change
date
on click
this
dot
change status
see let's change the status to
age of 0 to something
we will have to use this dot
set state
and inside we will use
a curly bracket
the state name so let's say h we want to
change
and let's increment the edge
to something
so we can say this dot state dot is
it by 2
so now
this state will be multiplied by 2 but
let's make it 1
because 0 to the 2 is will be 0
this is how we change straighten class
components
now click the button this will be
changed to
2
c
now it will be changed to 4
then 8 16 so on
to change the
name state we can use this or we can
also use in this as well
so we have here we are setting state of
the age
let's change the name
so we can say
name will be
this dot
set state wait what was it
this
or just let's make it something like
uday
now click the button say change state
it's there and this is changing as well
so we have to use state like this change
state like this
so this is how
set state works in class components
setting states
so
that's done
so we too we saw two examples in class
component and in functional component
so what are props
props are simply states like this name
that can be passed to other component
so let me create one component here
called
child
or children
chilled
okay just child.js
fine
let's make it functional component
so we have a child component here
so let me call this component in our
main name.js so we can say import
child from one step back child
now let me render it here
this
so see
okay let me make this an h1 tag first
h1
to make it bigger
saves so we have this child here
fine
so this is a child component that we're
rendering which is printing this h1 of
child here
but let's say we want to print the state
of name here
of nishant
so how do we do that we cannot create a
state here because it will not work we
have to we will have two states and it
will be useless
so to use this state in this style
component we will have to pass it
so to pass it we have to use prop
so we will have to use the prop
name which is called simply name
and then the value the state will be
inside this curly bracket
and this is the name
or this is a value that we will use in
the shell component to render this state
so
i will show you what i mean so let's say
we are passing name here
to call the name we will just use name
and in this h1 remove this child and
just say
name here
see it's called nishan now
so this name
that is here it's the first name
so if we change it to let's say
value
of prop
if we save this
we will not see anything here because
this name has not been this this name
doesn't exist
so we'll replace this
see now it's rendering fine
so the first value
is this name that we are printing here
and second is the value itself
that we are getting it from here
suppose now if we change the name to
something so let me create a button
say change name
so on the button we will have one click
event
and then we will simply do this
that name
do something let's say
that
save
now if we click click the button here
change name this name nishant should be
changed to udec because
proper dynamic so let's check this
change name
see
it's now there
so props are mainly used to transfer
data between parent component to child
component
so from parent to child
we can also transfer function controls
as well
let me show you what i mean so let's say
we have function
called
change name
so this function will not run
in this parent component it will run in
child component
so what will be what it will do it will
simply change the name
in this function set name this will be
so
we will pass the function as well like
this
save so here we are passing the value
and the function this is the function
and it's the value
so
similarly like this we have to receive
it here
change name function
so to trigger it we can simply use
button
and on click first let me add
change name
label here on the button
so on the button we will use only event
just like previously we did in the ch in
the parent component app.js
then we will pass the function name that
we are passing from here
save
now let me refresh to go back to nishant
now this button is in the parent child
component now
click it
and the name will be changed
successfully
so that's how prop works in react using
functions
one more thing that is to props is
let's say we want to pass a value from
here to
the parent component
let's say you want to pass something
like
hello
this
is
nishant
now this button will be clicked and it
will pass the value this string to this
function
so we don't need this right now let me
remove this
and we can simply
so see we are passing the value here in
the change name
so this function should accept a
parameter so let's say
some value
so if we console the value in
we will see it in the console
value
or else
if we want to set it here
it will be also work like that
it will also work like that
save
but let me change it to something else
like nishant
fine
now click the button
see it's nishant and open the console
now
we will have the let me change it again
we have the nissan one again because we
are passing the
name of nishant from
child to parent that's a hack
for props
let me explain it again
what is props so props is nothing but
sample variables like states which will
pass from parent component to child
component like this value
we can also pass functions
that like this function
and we can call the function using a
button or anything we want
like this here
third thing we can also pass
our or some value from child component
to parent component via this function
like a name or something
so here
we are passing this function change name
so change name is bidding passed here
using procs
it's coming here
and on click of this button we are
passing some value
so this value
will go to here in this value
and it will print in the console
so it's like a hack
so that's how props works in react
so here we have a simple example of this
if statement
if the age is 20 smaller than 26 we'll
print this
then else if
if both conditions are true we'll print
this
or if none is true we'll print the else
so we should see these two because these
conditions are true
open the console and let's check
okay see we are reading it two times but
don't worry about that that's the word
that the problem of this user vector
in the react rating version we cannot
solve this in this video because
it's not in our scope of this current
video topic
so let's convert in inside into this
inline condition
expression it goes like this
we have to check for h then
first is if age is more than 26
we will print
console
what is happening
console.
let's print
you
in this
course you
are
now old
see we are printing this
then we have else if
where we are checking these two
statements
so
we can press enter
or second line
you can write in the same line
but i am showing you for the clarity to
show you the full code properly
so here we are checking these two
statements so let's check
so
then comes else if
then again we have to check using
question mark
so again if this is true we will have to
print something
so we can say
let me first add a
fragment here
then we can say console.log
so
first console is this if this is true
let me add okay let me copy and paste it
here simply
okay just let me
copy it manually here
in quotes
then we have one more console.log
the second console
nishant is my name
save
so see
we are opening question mark here
and this closing here
so again after that we have to use the
colon just like this colon before
then we have to check for else
so we will do the same thing
we will use
a small bracket
then a
fragment
so for multiple form printing multiple
lines we'll have to use this
but if you have single line you can
simply use directly like this
then we have to print
these two statements
nishant is not my name
let me copy it simply and paste it here
nishanth is not my name
and i am less than 26 years old
um okay here
what's happening what's happening
now it's fine
let me comment out this
dave
so
let's check using the condition
aj is 26
fine
name is nishant
so it goes into this block
it will check the age
so it's under six so this one is not
true
this one is false so let's light false
here
then it goes inside the second block
else if
this one it will check name is nishant
yes it's nishant
age is this 26 yes it's 26.
here we are using ampersand 2 ampersands
it means
it will check for both conditions
both conditions
so
it will check for both it means
it though both should be true
so this will print this thing now open
the console to check
so this makes this as true so write it
true here
and
then it will not glow inside this block
so we can write it as false
so open the console
let's save this and check
we refresh the page once
we are getting this
i am 26 years old and nishant is my name
so this is getting fulfilled
let's change the condition here
obviously change the values
so we can say
let's say let's make this as
let's make this name as uday
fine
and let's make the edge as something
else
or let's leave it at 26.
so let's save and check what we get
so
start from the start meaning
edge is more than a six no it's false
still it's false
second block
it goes in it goes in it will check this
name is nishant no it's not nishan
it's uday
and the age is 26
this one is true
but we are using and here
so i said previously that if either of
them is false it will not go inside this
block
the both should be true for this
so again this should be this will be
false
then it goes inside here and will it
will print this as true
so now let's check
so this one is false
false third one will be true see we are
getting this
i am less than 26 years old and nishant
is not my name
so it's fine
now let's see how to use or
so this is condition
this is checking for both conditions
but what if you make it or
so it will check either of them
so if nishant is named and it is under
six of either one of them as true is
true it will print second one
save
refresh the page
it will say it's printing this
let's make it as true so it's true and
this one is again false
fine refresh once more i will explain
it's
not more than 26 so it's false
then it will come here
name is nishant not
it's not nishant it's there but the age
is 26
so it will print this
and it will not go inside this block
so it will print second one
so let's make the edge to be something
like
more than 26 let's make a 28
then it will print this one you are now
old
save refresh
so you have see we will get this message
called even now world
so now this first head band is getting
fulfilled so it's true now
then it will not go inside this else if
or else block
so both will be false
see so that's how ternary operator or
inline conditional expression works
let's say we had a third condition or
third statement let's say something
is varied or something else
then if you want to check it here you
have to add it in this false block
like this
so let's say is married
something
if it is true we will have to print true
or else
we have to print or print what is
whatever it is we have which is false
i think i get a you get what i mean
fine
that's how ternary operator or inline
conditional expression works and react
we can also use in html or jsx also here
so let's check whatsapp condition
so
just copy all these things
and add it here in curly bracket
paste it
but instead of console.log we will print
it in our h1 tag
so we can say
h1
let's check or let's add this here
remove console.log
and leave the command
then in second one we can print
or remove this and we can print h1
wait sorry we didn't have to remove this
h1
let's print this
and for second one let's print
this
remove these things
fine
and the for the third one wait a sec
we had
two html tags
okay and for the third one we have to
print
this
so what can we do we have to print this
fine so paste it here
save and
see
the problem here is
this age and name it's only inside the
use effect hook scope but not coming
here
so let me move it outside also or just
cut or copy and paste it here
and then it will work
c
so
ad78 and name is there
so it will go inside this block
it will print this as true because yes
the age is more than 26 28 26
828
let me reduce it to 286 then let's see
what it prints
it will print this
so let me make it an end
so it's printing i am okay where it's
my name should be here
fine
we are printing same thing twice
see
now this is true
so it's printing these two
so this becomes true
and this becomes
false
outside
the user factor
not inside there is effect hook
so
let me change the condition to something
else let's make it as
what is it the third condition is
nissan okay let's make it an ampersand
it will not follow because name is not
mishan
and this will now check for both
conditions name and age save you will
see this i am less than 26 years old
we are printing this
and nishant is not my name
so this now becomes false and this now
becomes true
because the values have been changed
here
so that's how
inline conditional expressions or
trinity operator works in react
so
what is even handling first
so event handling or functional handling
is a method to call functions an event
in react
using some input or buttons
on our using our actions so we can say
cons let's create a function first let's
say
add nums
we have a function
that basically will add two numbers
so
let me create a button it will say add
numbers
save
this button is there
fine
fine
so
we want to do something like we have to
add two numbers let's say
console.log let's add 2 n2 as 4 it will
be 4.
so let's say if this mercedes this was
simple html and javascript we have done
something like this
so on click
we have to open
codes so downloads
we have to call add nums
and
this bracket
but
this is not simple html and javascript
it's jsx and react
so this function will not add numbers
let me show you
what
we have
see
this property is invalid we have to use
this method
so add once again so it will not work
so instead of on click small on click we
have to use this
so let me remove this
and let's use
capital camel case on click
opening and closing curly brackets
then add the functions here which is add
nums
nothing else just this
see now if you click the button we will
see fold on the console
see
it's for now
so that's how this works
let me give you one more example using
an input element
let me create one input here
input
let's make the placeholder to be wait
what i am doing
this placeholder should be
adds
something
save
we have this input here
now let's say we want a function to run
every time we type something in the
input
so we can create a function to say const
get input
then we have to bind this function
to this input
if we are using html we will use
on change event like this
but not here this is not html we have
jsx so we will use camel case on change
and then we will simply pass get input
here
all the data that we type will be
propagated here in this function
get input so let me get the event from
here so we can console
dot log
our event dot target just let's make
first event first
the event that we are passing
you type something let's say one two
three four
see we are getting all the data from
this event like
all the data
so we want the target
so let's say event dot target dot value
the value of the target for this input
so let's type something like one two
three four five
then we will get this input here
similarly we have other things
like if we just add even target we will
see something like this
so
let me add a name property here
name of let's say input
so we have three things placeholder
on change and the name pro for this
input
fine
so if we type something like one two
three
we will get the whole input here
but we want
the value
so for the name so the value is you have
seen how to get the value to get the
name of this input we will say in
event.target.name like this
and if we type this input will be
propagated here
see
this input
so that's how event handling works in
react
so one more thing let's me let let me
show you
what do we want to pass some values to
this add
nums function dynamically from the
button
we will use this
it will be a function here we will call
a function then add num function
then we have to pass some property or
some data let's say we want to pass two
para parameters 2 and 2
then this will come here let's say
num1
and num2
we are using comma to differentiate
between them here also
so this is one number eight second
number let's make it three here
so num1 and num2
then we can simply pass it in the
console num1 plus num2
to get the input
so let's
add numbers and it's 5 see
that's how we do it in react
how to handle events
so a highway 2 array is there of numbers
and details
number contains numbers from 1 to 10 and
you see this detail contains
the name and age of 4 people in an
object
so first let me map the numbers array
and if you want to see how map works you
have to see my previous videos
in the same playlist
so we will have numbers
dot map
let's say number
it will return a list tag li
and here you will have to print all the
numbers
so this map will go over each and every
item and it will print the number like
this
but see if you open the console
what will what let's see what we see we
will see this error message
that each child in the list should
contain a key prop should have a key
prop
unique property so in this case all the
items are unique from one to ten
so to add keys here to re remove this
error
i will do key
and then add the number
here so now this key will take the
number
which is 1 to 10
so it will be unique and this message
will not be here anymore
so refresh the page
see it is not here anymore
so see this is the first scenario let me
enter the second scenario where all the
items
or all the elements
should be
should be not unique should be same
so in that case what can we do
so let me map this details first
and
we have a detail we will have a detail
here
let me remove the key from here and this
number and
num add detail and place the number
see
refresh the page
we will see this error that
objects in objects are not valid as
react child
so we have to render it using keys
okay fine the problem is
we have to use the name first also
that's this error
name
so this name is also key
this name has a key
let me add one more list here
but we have to wrap them in a fragment
because
two jsx elements cannot
exist without the parent
so
add it here
add one more list tag
this should be not name and age now we
will see all the edges here
let me comment this temporarily
see we have all the names and ages open
the console and i will see the same
error
for the keys
refresh the page
see we are saying this
each child in a list should have a
unique key prop
but we don't have anything that's unique
here
let's say we have a name but name can be
same for two people
we have a age and this could be same as
same as well
so let me demonstrate this to you
let me add
a property one more property with the
same name and h of challenge
then we will try to add a key using the
age let's see what we get
so
first make this a div
and
copy and paste here
then let's add the key prop
and the key should be the age
so
detail dot age
see we will see that
warning encountered two children with
same key 29 k should be unique
so that the components maintain their
identity and all so we are getting this
error
so in this case we have two options
first we can add one ids here so id
let's say one
then here should we add ids 2
and then
3
then
4
and then there at the last we'll have 5
then we can print the key as simply
detail.id detail.id
now this error won't be here
see it's not here anymore
second scenario is that if we don't have
the ids let me revert it back or leave
it let's say we don't have the ids let
me comment this
alt
alt alt
alt
let me
move it alt alt alt alt
shift alt alt
again
alt alt alt alt
alt
shift
aerospace back remove all the ids
now see
let's say we don't have the ids in this
current scenario
therefore we can use an index property
here
so this map also returns one index that
we can use as the key which will be
unique
throughout the
array
see not the error has been disappeared
but this index thing is a last resort
kind of thing
so if we don't have the id only then we
have to use index or else add the ids
here in the array or in the object
or in the api
so that's how keys works in react and
how to
fix them so mainly
the keys are called the name and age
and in this case all the items are
called keys
fine so that's all about keys in react
here i for input fields from name to it
name age hobbies and date
and one empty error function
first let's get data from the form
inputs this is the first step
so we will use an event called on change
event
that will run when the input field value
changes or we type anything in the input
field keep that in mind
so we will use this get input function
in the on change event
this will pass an event
argument here in the function
then we can simply console this thing
this event
so open the console
let me type my name in the name field
called nishant
see we are getting all this data here
all the data
most of which we don't need
so to fix this or to like
yes fix this
we can only send the data we need
directly so let's say event
we can send let's say you want the value
that we type lot which is target dot
value
value
we can do this
here let me make the event to value
and here as well now we will only get
the data that we're typing the text
so we can add nishanth here
and we will get that
so let me repeat this all over
the first step is
done i mean the first lesson for forms
now what can we do is let me so let i be
added the unchanged event here
let me also add the name property
so each
of the input fields will have a name so
let's say this will be a name
this should be the age
this should be
age
sorry not age let's say name this should
be
hobbies
and they should be uh date
so all of these now have a name as you
can see
fine
let me also pass the name
this will be event dot
target dot
name
like this
so let me pass
them all over
so this name is also important
i will show you why
see
now we have the name
basically we are passing to values here
okay we are passing to values like value
and the name so we have to receive two
values so name
if we console the name here let's say
what we get
refresh the page
we can say name as nishant
and if we type even if you're typing in
the name field this field we will get
the corresponding name if it is age we
will get the age
age we are getting and same for hobbies
and data
let me make
okay fine
now let me
show you the types of the input fields
we will can have the type
prop
and we can add
text
for the alphabeticals like nishant or
like if we want text here simply numbers
and text i mean numbers and alphabets
for the age which could they should only
be a number
so we can add the type as
type as equal to
number
like this
for the hobbies so now this is a number
and refresh the page
see
we cannot type alphabets here we can
only type a number
like this fine so for third one we can
also add
the text as same as the name because
there should be a text as well
but for the first one we can add
the date
type so we have so many types like input
date color so let me show you let me add
or
let me just make this type as
input
this now will be a file upload thing
type is okay not input file file yes
this should be a file upload thing
so revert it back and let me remove this
why
so we have four fields and all of them
have the type
and the name
with the on change events
so now let me
console the value
so console.log
the name and value
small value i mean
value
open the console
or let me do it like this to make sure
we have name
colon and the value
wrap it in a very like thing then it
will
not work okay okay okay
let me wrap it in an object like this
then this should be an area like this
like this so we will have
the name
paired with the value like uh
key value pairs so this name will be the
key that we will store and the valuable
the value that we will have
so refresh
me add my name nishant and see
the name is the key and this nishant is
the value
c
fine
now let me store them in an
array sorry not an array let me store
them in a object so if you want to show
all the values or store the values in a
state you can create multiple states
for us we will have four states for name
age hobbies and date but i will show you
how to do it using only one state an
object state
you can because for example if you
create four states
then you have to assign all the four
state and set state in all the on change
events which will be lengthy so let me
introduce you to a new method
so we can say const
let me create a state an object state so
let's say
obj data
and set
obj data in campbell case so you state
this will be an object just like
this
so we will we will keep storing all the
data in an object
yes wait what happened okay yes we'll
keep storing all the
object properties in the set object in
the object data state
so we have to store
this in an variable first so let's say
let
data equal to
just copy
this whole thing
cut and paste
remove this
now this data will contain our
data like this
so for example if we console the data
here clg
console.log data
let's see what we get
refresh
let me add the name called nishant
we are reading the name and
the value like well sorry we are getting
the key
name and the value nishant here like
number eight
if we type the age 26 we will get the
age only
like this
we are not getting the name anymore
because it has been overridden by the
age
so we have to store this data
in this set
in this object data state
so we can do
small bracket then curly bracket
then we will have to merge them so for
example
let's say we are storing this data here
using using spread operator like this
now we can console data the data outside
like this
now let's see what we get it refresh the
page
so let me explain once more what i am
doing here
we are merging the data using key value
pairs in the data variable let data then
we are storing the data as object in the
set object set
in the object statistic i mean then we
are consoling it here
let me add my name called
nishanth so it's here c
so it's getting stored in the object
data state successfully
if we add the age
the previous data will be overwritten
like this we don't see the name anymore
but we have a name in the input as well
so to solve this we will have to add the
data and then merge with the previous
data
so name will be the previous data so
we'll merge it using like this
triple dots then object data
we will merge the both objects
so the previous data now is called
nishant and the new data is called this
let me start from the beginning
let me add the new data
which is nishant
and it's here in the console and the
state of object data over the data
now let's say we want to add the age
now this nishant is now the previous
data and the age is now the new data
let me add the age
26 and see they have been both merged
together
the previous data and the new data
now
this both
properties like agent name they are the
old data previous data and if you write
the hobbies
this will be the new data
so we can say
let's say hobbies is
creating
videos
like this so now this is the
old data
like this is the old state now
and if we add the date
here this will be the new state
so all these three fields are in the
world state and this one will be the new
state let me choose some date here
20.
now we have the data as well and all
these four are now in the old data which
is object data
so that's how it works
that how we can minimize
the
code
so what can
we do now so see
let's try to submit the form or let me
yes so we can they we can create a
function called const submit
so we can use the submit function in two
ways
let's say i want to sum in data and show
in in the console or send the data to an
api
so we can say console.log
this
object data
we have a button here that can run the
function on click event
using one click event so we can say
on click
submit button submit function
now let me try from the start write the
name nissan age 26 hobbies
let's say recording videos
and the date
from today's date
click submit
the data will be here
in the console line number 13
here
another method is
not
using this submit
on not using this only given
we can use
onsubmit on a form tag here
so wrap
online puts in a form tag like this
this will also work
so
make the button inside as well
so now all of these inputs will be
inside this form
or what we can do we can add the form
outside the div because the design is
breaking
so let's check
so let's check if it is working or not
yes it's working
so now in the form we have to use
on submit
one event on submit and let me assign
submit function here
but still now it will not work because
this button has to be a submit type so
type should be
submit
so if you open the console now
let me type the name
age
hobbies and the date
now click submit
and see
if you submit it's coming here but
instantly it's getting disappeared
so here what we have to do is we have to
do
a thing so let's say
we have to send the
okay
so we have to do this so this should
contain an event param
or e
then you can do event
dot prevent diff
prevent
default to prevent the default
function here so now click or just add
the name
the age
hobbies
and the date
now click submit
it's here now it's not getting refreshed
automatically if we just comment this
and now click submit the form will be
refreshed
see
that we don't want fine
all right
so we can add one more button here that
can be used to reset the form
let me also show you that it is set
and the button type will be reset
if you click the button of reset the
whole form will be reset
add the name
the age
hobbies and
some date
now click submit
it's here now let me click the reset
button
see all the data has now been reset so
that was how to use react forms or forms
in react
so for example let's say we have three
fields here
name age years of experience
these three are simple but let's say we
had
like 10 or 11 inputs
in that case
if we want to get data
how to do that
we have to create let's say we had 10
inputs
then we had to create
10 different states for 10 inputs for
one for each input for example for name
we have one state for age we have one
state
for this we have one state and so on but
here we will show i will show
how to do it using only one state and
one function
that's very simple
first of all we will create a function
called
get input
or let me make it get input value like
this
like this like this
fine
now let's add the name properties here
that's very important so this input of
name
will be have a name of name
this input we have this input of age
will have the name of h and this one as
years of experience we can say yoe
like this
so
it's done all the three have names
now let me assign
the get input values function using on
change event on these
inputs like
this
or if you want you can also do directly
call the whole function
like this one change
now
this in this this this this this on
change event let's say we type something
in the here like nishant this will send
some data to the well do the function
here we can mark it as event
let's mark it as data for your
convenience
and for mine
fine
if we console.log this data we will get
all the information about the first form
field if we type in the name
so let me show you
bring this down
console
let me add my name called nishant
so we will have all these things here
bubbles cancelable blah blah blah blah
blah blah fine
it's done but we need two things here
so we need this a data dot
target
dot value
so we need only the value first
i will show more later
but
soon
we have the name nishant because we're
typing nishant here
if we type page we will see the age
from the second field years of
experience let's say 2 it will show up
here
here
here fine
but as
i did here we also need the name
to get the value name or input name we
can just make in turn into target name
now if you type the name in the first
field you will not get the value we will
get the name this name if we type age we
will get this age
just like that
so
we have the name and the value
we also have the id i think so let's try
id
refresh the page
so let's say we add the name of nishant
it's empty um
so i think
idn name works the same so let's say if
we add the id of
name
let's see now what we get
so let's add the name nishant and the
ids name here so this id
and name props works the same
so we will use name here
fine
then
what can we do um okay so we are getting
the data but let's restructure this data
and we will have to we have to extract
the name
and value from this data
so we will do
this let we will create
two variables this is called structure
in javascript
we will create the name and value
from this data
like this
and it's done now if we console
the name
we will get the name
refresh
and the name nishant okay we are getting
undefined hmm
okay data.target we need to do here yes
because data is not sufficient now i'll
get the
name here
so at the name nishant and we are
writing the name here successfully
let me draw value
let me try value nishan and the name is
here nishant
we have to structure them properly
now what we will have to do is we have
to
create
a
variable called let
let's say input
we have to mark
these two inputs as key value pairs
like
this open curly brackets
then in this array we'll have the name
as the key
and the value as the value
so this is the key and value just like
in an object we have key value pairs we
have this here
if we clg or console log
this input let's see what we get
so at the name nishant we are reading
the name as key value players here if we
add the h we will get the age like this
fine
now let's create a state just like we
discussed one single state not three
states
for three different fields so we will
have to import the use state hook first
use state hook like this
let me create a state here let's say
cons
data okay let's say
inputs and set
inputs
equals to use state let me make this
edge
and
what can we make this as object like
this
or we do we need an object or do we need
an array um
what we have to do here is we have to
set it inside let's do with object it
will work
then we will set
this
set input
then we will set this input in this
input state
like this but we will have to use like
this
this input is a
object and they will we will merge it
with the previous object
so we'll merge
the inputs with the input state like
this
now we have a dynamic field here dynamic
input fields
and we don't need to create 10 states
because
we have done it with only one
so if we console.log
the input state
so initially it's empty because our
three fields are now empty
so let me add the age sorry we let me
add the name
then the age
then the years of experience
and now we are getting all of them in
one single state
so
we can show them using this input state
let's say you want to send data to an
api we can simply send this input we
don't have to send
name as name ages age and years of
experience as years of experience
so that's how it works
dynamic inputs in react
so mainly we have three ways first way
is called external styling the way we
are using it right now and the commonly
used way
see we have this css file that's getting
imported into app.js
then we have a class name in this div
of app
and we are rendering the style here
using app cue app class name
let me demonstrate it from the beginning
we can make an h1
that will say hello world
like this we will have h1 here one h1
so
let me make two more adjustments
or let me just change the text here this
should be
external
tile
link
copy this
add it
two more times this should be
internal
inter
null
this should be in line
so these are the three types of styling
external internal and inline in react
so
this external is clear i think we can
simply add a class name of
let's say
external
external copy the class
add it here
and then we can say
we can say
let's say
color
of red
the color of the first
h1 will change
which is external styling
right
so the cache is we have to import our
app.css file here so if we comment to
this
the starlight will not work
because this yes and index.css sorry
i've got cs file they are not linked
together
so this was the one type of styling
external
now let me talk about internal styling
where we will write the styling in our
app itself the js file
we can create a const
we will say
styles
equal to an object
inside we can simply say this
let me make
the class name of internal then
a colon then again opening object
brackets
let's say the color should be red here
fine
then
here in the internal styling we can say
style keyword we will use this
we will use the styles const
dot internal
we need to target
the color of red which is inside
internal save
and see second one is now red let me
make it to
blue
to make it clear see it's now blue
so this was internal styling
third one is called inline
where we write
styles
or the style fine
and we write directly the styles inside
for example let's say color
we can say green
save
and it's now green
like this
we can have if you want to add multiple
styling here let's say we have to change
the background color of
this third h1 we can say
background color
has
black
black let me type
black
and it's now black like this
you must be asking why do you use
the
internal and inline stylings i will show
you
let me create a button first here
button
that will say
toggle theme
suppose we are making a app or maybe
let's say we just
we're just adding
a function to change the theme of the
page like from dark to white and to
white to dark
so
we have to we have a button here of
toggle theme
let me create a function const
toggle theme
this will be an arrow function
this button for a function will be on
this button
so on click
this function will run when we click the
button of toggle theme
fine
we also need one state so let me create
it which will be toggled
on the button click it will be called
uh
let's say
theme
and set
theme you can choose any name you want
equals to use state
this will be a false value first
false value
okay use state is not defined we have to
use
react dot used
so it will be a boolean state and on the
button click
this function this state name will
revert so
the state value will revert i mean so
for example if it is
false it will be true and vice versa
now we will use this theme to change the
styling of the
page
as per the theme
so for example let me remove this
or what can we do yes in the style
we will do
theme but first let me create one more
internal css styling dark
here it will be background color
as not black white
and color will be black color
will be black
we need one more light
here it will be different
background color will be black and color
will be white
opposite to dark
same styles but it's not okay fine
so
let me remove this internal styling
so i will implement the dark and light
theme like this so if the theme
is true
okay let me
okay if the theme is false initially
we will show the light theme and how to
shoot the light theme we can say style
or styles dot
light
light
l i g ht
or else we can so we can show i mean
styles dot
dark
fine
it's done
now on click of the button the theme
will change it will
toggle click the button
okay it's only working in the second h1
we have to make it
outside the h1 i mean in the main app
here so just add it here
refresh the page so initially it's him
not light
fine
so if it is false
wait a second
it is false initially fine
so it's if it is false i will show this
or this
click the button toggle theme
so now it's true
wait a second i think we have to remove
this let me check
because this doesn't make any sense
it falls
so
we are showing
if it is true
we can show
this
or this
wait a second
okay background color okay we did
something wrong here they should be
light
and they should be dark we did opposite
now initially
it's black because
this theme is false the value is false
so we are showing this else one and if
you want to know how this question mark
works please see my video about
inline conditional operators or ternary
operator
refresh the page once
now toggle theme
okay let me do this
just remove these things first
so
we are having removing we remembered
that and this one as well
so h1s are now all white refresh
see it's white
now the h1 and the background is black
if we click toggle theme it will revert
the h1 is now black and the whole screen
is now white
so in that case we use
the internal styling
or inline
so for inline we can do this as well
so let's say
in this same style we can do this remove
all these things if theme is true then
question mark
then we can say
um
this
add this
fine but
wait a second
we have to do it like this so if the
theme what is the theme
this theme
if it is true
we can create one more curly bracket
and we can write our styles inside it
that will say like
color
if it is true it means
so if it is false let me bring the color
to black
text color
and
background color
as
white
and outside
this style curly bracket we will add one
more
for
white and black so
this color will be white
and the background color will be
black
save and now it will work
let me
remove this
here
and just get the style from here and add
it in this main div
now let's try
toggle theme
so it's now white see toggle them again
it's now black so this is how it works
in both scenarios for inline and
internal
so let me add it here
get the
things and i will push the code
for you to read
fine
save it and that's all for now
also remember don't forget to
add the advert css
import here
or else it will not work
what is the control component in there
for example let's say we have two inputs
and we are handling the data inside our
component
in the same component
but in uncontrolled components we handle
the data from the dom we get the data
from the dom using a reference value
so let me show you now how to do it
first for uncontrolled components
for example
let's say we have to input name an h
like this
localhost okay we have name image like
this let's say we want to
add reference to the both
we will create a name variable called
name
equal to then we will use
we'll create a reference for the name we
will use react dot
create ref
like this
then we can say for age we can say let
age
equals to react dot create ref
create ref
so this will create the reference for
name and age
fine
now i will assign this references to
the inputs
using the ref keyword ref equals to
here will be the name
and in second one here will be the age
sorry age
yes
now
let me now show you to console
now let's console the log name
console.log
name
dot current dot value
and here console.log
name dot current dot age
let's try to see what we get
we should get an error
because we don't have any data inside
them
if we check in the inspect element
we will something like
this
cannot treat properties of null reading
value
so
if we remove them
wait okay i think
let's just add niman age first
age
this should work now yes
now refresh the page we will get empty
current values here
so we can say name dot current that will
be null
so it doesn't matter
i'm just gonna type my name here in the
nishanth
see
we are not getting anything
if we type some edge
still nothing
we are not getting the console up
because
our state is not getting refreshed sorry
our component is not getting refreshed
and then we cannot see the name image
to do that we can simply create a
function if you want to see the name
image
let's say submit
and add a function put them inside here
this name images
then on this button we can simply on
click event this
one click the submit button function i
mean
now if we close if we just click submit
button only then we can see a manage
because only then our dom is getting
refreshed click submit
and see we are getting these two
so
we have to do name dot current
dot value
and h dot current not value
okay
value
now let's check
click submit
now we're reading the values of nishanth
and 25 so my like the main point here is
in the unknown components
we don't have or we don't have the
privilege
to
get our states updated or component
updated automatically
if we are creating a reference like this
but now let me show you control
components that we generally use
okay
so we will create a use statement first
or wait a second
okay yes let me create i use statehook
or do we need it no we don't need let me
create a function so const
get input
or let's say git name
get name equal to an arrow function
fine
now
we will not use this okay let me just
copy and
paste it once more
so this will be
on
let me just try it and
uncontrolled
component
is that component
component
spelling is wrong
components
let me commend this
then inside the second one let's write
control
come
[Music]
in let me comment this also because
here we having we are having
uncontrolled components that we showed
before
and here control components remove this
rift
and this edge
we can also command this temporarily for
now here fine
now we have only one name image
here inputs fine
so for the get name
or uh okay we can use on change event
here for control components we use on
change event
so if we type something this git name
function will run
and it will pass the value so we can say
event
here we can simply console.log the event
event.target.value
target
dot value like this
okay fine now let's check
refresh the page type something in a
name like say nishant
so see
here we are reading that name
if we type n and we'll come here then
and i such so it's getting appended
every time we type inside it and the
same thing is for
the age
so we can say get age
here should we
add on change
on change
event get h
now in the age we will see the age if we
type the age let's say we type
2 6
so now we're getting the h
now in this case our component is
getting
refreshed or what is it called
here it should be the word our component
is getting um updated
where is it where is it where is it
okay this is not here okay okay
okay
okay
it's not here so you have to believe me
in this case our component is getting
refreshed but in the previous case of
create riff our component will not be
refreshed because we are just getting
the value
from the dom
so that's what
that's what is
controlled and uncontrolled components
in react
first of all what is what's well done
the virtual dom or v dom is a concept
where the entire ui
is being kept in the memory
and it's being synced with a real dom
now how it works
let's say we have some state and it
changes
then the component will render again
and again
every time some state changes
if the state is changing and the
component is getting red ended
the virtual dom will be updated as well
now if the virtual dom is getting
updated it will be compared to the
real-time
like this
we have the blue nodes the previous
nodes on the left
the left is the entire virtual dome and
on the right we have the real talk
so this blue nodes are the data what is
the ui
before
state updation or before we're rendering
the component
let's say we change something and saved
the component will be rendered again
and we have we will have this grey nodes
here
the new nodes after state
update now
the entire virtual dom will be updated
or will be compared to the real dom
like this
so it will check we already have the
blue nodes here in the real dom
we don't need to change the blue nodes
we only need to change the gray nodes
also called updated new nodes
then it will append the gray nodes to
the real dom like this
now this becomes the new real dome
and
nothing else will change only the
updated nodes will change
this grey nodes updated new nodes
and the entire process is called
reconciliation in react
so that's virtual dom and how it works
so first of all let's see what is in an
html
so in html is a property
that that prints or displays all the
contents of a element
with the tags html tags
let's say for example we have a let
variable
it has a data let we have let a time in
let's add
this this is called string literals
fine
so inside the data
we have p tags
that says this is
my home save this
see now if we print data
in this div
we will see
with the p tags here
with the p tags
so let's say we want to remove the p
tags from here
and just print this this is my home
or let's say we have some styling here
div style sorry p style equal to
quotes
and let's say we had something like font
size
colon
20 pixels
this will show up here
instead of applying the styles
fine
so how do we do that how will we print
the speed tag with the font size of 20
pixels
in the
text of this is my home
so it's very simple we will not use the
data variable inside the div let me make
one more div here
we will not write anything inside the
div
in the area we write
we will simply do this we will use
dangerously set in html we will use this
keyword
we will have two opening brackets sorry
look two curly brackets
inside we will use
two
underscores
then we will type html because we are
printing html
then we will add the variable that we
want to print which is data
save and now see
we are reading this is my home text
here
if we change the font size to 25 pixels
this will increase the size
let's also add the color color should be
red
see now it's in the red color fine
one more thing let me show you this
data this like this tag p
this is not jsx this is html
for example let's say we have i want to
print the same thing here
in
the return we will not use it like this
way we will use
like this
which is if let's say font size
25
and color
red
see this will print the same thing here
but instead of
here we have html i mean this is html
and this one is called
jsx let me
comment jsx
this is
this is html
and this one is called
jsx fine
in html we are printing like a string
in quotes
but in
the jsx we have seen camel case inside
two curly brackets like this
let's add one more
example
data 2
but not p tag we will use b tags bold
attacks
fine
let's add data to inside one more
variable here let me just copy and paste
it
so data two
it will print the same thing but in bold
if you make the color to let's say blue
this will be now in blue color
so this is html printing inside
the data and data too then we are
displaying the contents using inner html
for react we don't have any html we have
this
dangerously set in html like this
so that's how we do it now let me give
you one more tip
let me open one what is it uh ndm
package
it's called react quill
see
let me stall this first
it will take some time but
not much
so
this thing is mainly used for
like
markup for example okay wait
ports we have to use every time
okay let's say we are writing a blog
or we are making you are making a
website on a writing blog website
so in that case we can use
this
quill package and then generally set in
html i will show you why
so we have installed the package here
let me do one additional thing let me
remove
okay let me remove
wait in the index.js right let me remove
stick mode
save this
now
come over to app.js here same thing
really same
let me import this
react wheel from react
then we need to import the css
the same way we did
in es6 like this
then we have to
open or render the react query layer
save this
and refresh
we don't need these two right now
because we don't have the functions
no see
we have this text area where we can type
anything
fine
let me create a function here
okay okay
const get cool
data equals to something
so this function will run when we on
change this react way
just like this so on change
the function
so we also need one state so let me
import react first
import
react from react
let me create a state
const let's say
quill and set
coil
use state use state this will be an
string because we will type text now in
the function we will simply have a value
our argument arg
given
and i will set
the value inside the set query state
now in this quill we have some data if
we type something here okay
use state is not defined so we can add
react.edu state
like this
now if we type something this data will
be stored inside the sql state
if we console dot log
the sql let's see what we get
open the console
clear the console now okay just type
something like
nishant see we are getting the text in
the p tags
if we just render the quill
here wait a second where is it
if we render the quill in this html let
me remove this one fine we will see that
same text here
refresh the page
we don't see anything
also remove this one
or just comment it out fine
we are not saying anything let's type
something called
and i guess a chain t nishant
so this text is directly getting
rendered to this html in the inner html
also called
dangerously set in a html it's getting
rendered
and here also in the console line number
15 14.
if we make this as bold
this one will be bold as well see we are
having this p and strong text
and it's getting rendered here at the
top
we want to change the color
or the font size let's make as heading
one
now the font size has now been increased
in h1 and strong tags previously it was
p tag and now it's h1 tag
let's change it to
list
okay let me just make some list here
first
we can say one
it will automatically be in list
in the ol
order list and then li
we will have
item
1 enter
item 2 and the items are getting
rendered at the top
with the tags directly
let's take an example first let me
print an h1 in the return
called hello
hello hello
it will work we can say hello on the
screen
if we print another h1 let's say world
it will give it an error that says
adjacent jsx tags must be wrapped in an
enclosing tag
or this fragment
so the workaround to this is using a div
here
like this
let me add one more closing div at the
last
okay not here
okay what a sec
save this
all right
we shouldn't get this here
so let me wrap it in and what is
happening here yeah
so we have h1 let me add a div
and add the last here
see if now it will work fine it's
working we have hello and world
now we will not get that error
because we have a diff parent element
that is enclosing this two h ones
fine but we have a disadvantage of using
this div
because
this div creates a new node in the
react dom element
that's not preferable
only preferable or we can only use this
div in one case
when we have the
like the arrangement of a grid
like this let me show at the class name
grid here
and dot grid
if we have this display of grid here
like this and or other things
so
and one more example let's say flex
so this div can only be used when we
have to use the class name like div or
like uh graderflex or any class name
here
let's say app
now
yes if we don't have app here let me
bring app
and we will simply text align a center
so we will only use this div in only one
case when we have
to use the class name here
but let's say we don't have to use a
class name
we can simply use
this
a called a fragment
or we have one more item here
let me import react first import react
from react
then inside we can simply say react dot
fragment
and add this here
so see
it's the same so we can either use
reacted fragment
or its short form
simply an opening angle brackets and
closing one at the last
so that's how
we do
fragmenting in react
now this becomes a fragment and if we
repeat it once more
we will get the same merit because now
this fragment and this fragment
is now
adjacent x
and we have to use one more
fragment to enclose the both
so if we add one more fragment this will
work
see you will see hello world and hello
world four times
you can also use regular fragment here
i am just showing for your clarification
so add it here
and it's done
so that was react fragment or
fragment in react remember
we cannot use class names here so if we
add
class names we will see there is no
option
of class names here
if we add the app
it will not work
we will still see the same thing that we
are saying that we were saying before
so if you want to use class name you
will have to use div
but
the div creates additional notes
in the
reactor
that means only use diff when it's
necessary otherwise use reactive
fragment
or its short
form
and that's all about react fragments in
react
so what is the status component
stateless component means with no states
for example this component here is
called stateless
we have nothing but a div and one h1
that makes us stateless
stateless means triple equal to no
states
but what about stateful
let me add one state here so stateful
means
the component which states
for example
if we add a state of name
and set
name
equals to u state
let me add the
initial value of nishanth
and add the hello so i replace the hello
with name
it will print my name here
now
this will become stateful component
it
pull
or which states
if
fine
so simply put stateless means with no
states
stateful means which states this
component is now stateful because we
have a set of name here
one more tip
before the react 16.8 version
if we wanted to use stateless component
we would have used function component
because
we don't we didn't have any method to
create states
for function component before this
version
but after the version
we had react hooks that allowed us to
create states
just like we did now using your state
hook
so that's all now
that was the route that's what that was
all about stateless versus structural
component in react
so mainly we'll use a library called
axios so let me install it we can say
npm i x use
and my app is not running so let's start
the app and then start
fine
so this api requests wait a second
of course
like this yes
so mainly
the requests are of four types
post request to add data in the database
post then we have read
or we can say get to get it on the
database
we have put our pass to update and we
have delete to delete the
document from the database from the api
so we have four
api request types we can say
post request
get request
put request put or patch
anything okay let me make capital put
our patch
and delete
let me make the post to the capital like
this fine save
post put get and delete we have this
four types of requests in
what is this
okay so we have four times the request
mainly that we
normally use
so
i have a mock api and here we can send
our data or request first let me create
the mock api we can say the project name
as api
requests
re
quests
then
leave all these things click create
it will create a api request project
we can say new resource
let me add the end point of
let's say
users we don't need all of these things
just leave that user id
then click create
and here you see we have all the
endpoints
for get for post put and delete
so 48 we can simply we have simply pass
the id like this
for update rd
post we just have to post using slash
users and
forget we can have two endpoints to get
all the users
and to get one user so click create
first i will show you later
what is all these things
now we have received that same point
here if you open this
you will see it here
it's currently empty with no data inside
so xcos has been installed now
let's import the library here
we can simply say import
import axios
from
axios like this
right
let me create a function
the const
pose data
it will be an arrow function
fine
so in the post data
we will add this so we will have xcos
dot post method
because we are using post data i mean we
are posting data
or sending data to the database
then we will copy the end point and we
will simply add it here
this url
we got is the end point for posting data
to the
uh here to mock api is this database
then second thing it takes is
one
curly bracket we will have to open and
the thing it takes is the data itself
first
is the link or the end point
second is the
data itself so let's say we post some
name called
nissan
let's say have some age called
26
let's say some hobbies
so we can make an array here
always will contain
let's say
poetry
[Music]
then second thing it will contain will
be
cooking
then third thing let's add traveling
traveling fourth thing let's add
programming or let's say coding
that's what i'm doing right now
oh let's add one more which is
piano
fine so we have all this
things like name string
this one is number and this one is an
array
fine
so
when this function runs
it will post the data to the smog api
so we need one button to trigger the
function
so we can say
post
data
on click of this button we will have
this post data function
and as soon as we click the button of
post data
it will send data to this api
let's try this and one more thing let me
show you open the network tab
open the console
i mean the
inspect and the network tab
so whatever we are having the call
whatever call we are having api call
this will show up in the networks tab
in the chrome web tools
or chrome dev tools okay yes
now click post data
see this api has been called and it's
sending the payload means the data we
are sending
which is
the which has the age all the hobbies
that we wrote
statically and the name nishant
if we check the preview we will see the
same thing but with id
so the payload where is it okay
this payload it means
payload this payload is means the
payload means
the data we are sending to the api call
this preview means the data we are
receiving from the call reviewer
response
they are same
okay see now we are adding we are
getting one id also here this is a
response
and the payload is the request
so request we sent and it is pawns we
got if we refresh the api here
we should see the data here
in an array like this
so you can make all of this dynamic by
using a form field for example let's say
i have input
placeholder of
name
let's add a state here let me create a
state first
if you know what is states they are
simply variables
in react we have to import use statehook
from react sorry
used it from react
then let's create a state called
let's say
state of name
and set name
currently we don't need set name but
let's just create it
let it be empty
and first
then
on okay we need we don't need set name i
was wrong
so on change of the input we will simply
call set name
or we can simply set the
target.value in the set name or name
variable
name state using event dot target
dot value
not validation message value
if
now whatever we type in this name it
will be
stored inside the name state let me
bring the button after the input
and
in the name we can simply add the name
property like this
now let's try to add some data let's say
name should be chalice
shall is click post data
so it has been sent and see now the same
has been changed to sales
it's not static now it's dynamic
depending on the input
and here also we will get the same thing
but the name will be challenged
see
that's all for post method
now let's check the get method how it
works
get means
getting all the data from
the users
so let me store or well let me show you
one more thing
see
if i add this then block here
and response
in the post we can use
what is it we can say a promise
so console.log we can check our promise
using this it means when the post api
call is complete we will have some input
in the console
or in our ui
or if it is an error if the post method
fails it will show us an error
so we can simply console.error
this error like this
now if you open the console
click something like uder
and click post data
okay it's not coming here
post name okay let
check network
okay this hasn't been called i think
open console
refresh the page okay now it's here
see
we can see all the data we can just
simply call res dot data to get this
data
object inside
save this
and now it will
return the data only
click some else something else like avi
shake
click post data
it will take some time but it will be
here because i think
it's a little bit slower
see now we have this with hobbies that
all the static values and the dynamic
value of team
so that's it and in case of any errors
we will get an error in the console not
this
so that was promise after api call
fine
now what was i going to show you
okay yes get request
so in this api we have all the data
like the way the data is sent here
if we refresh we should get it
now let's get them
to get them we will use then use the
fact hook here sorry yes use the fifth
hook
that will run when our page mounts
for the first time only
but now
we can change it as per our needs
so add an empty array here for it to
work here we are calling axios.post
but here we can simply call xcos.get
already call the data
so copy this endpoint user's endpoint
and just simply paste it here
fine and we can do the same thing here
as well
so when the post is complete it will
return some promise then in cash block
and in the get request as well it will
return some promise like it like then in
catch
but in this case we will get all the
data
so save and let's try refresh the page
see we are getting four arrays for four
ready objects
of all the data we're getting here
forwarded objects let me store them in
an
array state so say const
let's say um
let's say
data or say users
and set
users
this u state this will be an array
because
this is the whole array
we are getting we have to set this whole
array in
the state of users like this
not in the post in the get
so
that's done that's how it is useful then
catch block
fine
so now this users have our all the data
when we load
we can simply do this
user dot map
let's say user
it will return something like
let's say one fragment first
then it will return us and h1
that will have the user
dot name
let's only print the name for now
so we have all the names here okay let
me make this h2 equals because it's
much bigger
fine
now we have all the names here like this
fine
so we are getting all the names and that
was get request so we have done post and
get
now let's try
updating the data
how will we update the data
so let's create a function
to update the data
updation is similarly similar to this
post data
but a few changes is needed
so const
update data
equals to an error function like this
fine
now we have to create a button here
in this
fragment
button
say update
so we will have to specify which
document to update or which data like we
have to update the nishant one
challenge or the aura we say we have
which we which field we have to update
we will use the id
because see we have this id and it's all
unique we have one two three and four
for each one this is one this is two
three and four okay let me do this
before this user dot name we can simply
do user dot id
let's print the id
and let's add a dot here
dot and a space
we have the dot let's add the space but
it will not work
so we will do
this
wrap this in string literals
like this and add a
dollar i think i'm doing it wrong wait
let me clear it out
we can say string literals
yes or wait i think it is like this
string literals
we can use again a string literal again
sorry not string little curly bracket
then we will have user
dot id
inside the string literals we will have
one more curly bracket
and we will use user dot name
in this way we can give a space between
them and one dot
so
one dot nissan two dot challenge three
note to the end photo to be checked
so all of these have an id one two three
and four
on base of this id we will update the
data
update the
array object so we can say on click
when we click the button
we have to send this id
to a function which will be this
function update data
so we will send the id or user.id
like this
let's
uh get the id from
the function here
and if we console.log this id let's see
what we get
open the console
clear it click any field like nishan
we are heading one click challenge we
will get two and so on now we have a
unique parameter called id that can be
used to update the
records
fine
so for update
method
we will have to use x use
dot put or patch
so we have an output method then we will
add the end point this end point
add it
thing it takes
is the data
which will be
the new data so let's copy
these things
these three things
and add it here
so it has been added all these three
things
so
let's alter some things
see initially the age is 26 for all
let's make the edge to be 27
let me add one more
object here or add a field here called
let's say
we have poetry cooking traveling coding
piano let's say sleeping
save
and
third parameter it will take will be the
id itself
so we can simply pass
the id like this
so we are getting all this giving it all
the things that it needs
then we will have to use this then and
catch block
so then will be called in case it is
successful
or catch in case if it fails
so let's try remove this console log
open the console
so you can also use network type to see
the request
so
let's add some name here called
let's say
what can we add the name here let's say
sanji
now click nishant update here
okay
console.error is not a function we have
something wrong open the network tab see
that through an error
because
we are having an error
so actually we did a mistake here we
don't have to send the id here like this
because
it's not in the query query it's in the
path params so if we check
this documentation let me let me click
the project
let me check
how to do this
new resource
see if you check here
in the put we have to pass the id like
this after the end point
so cancel it
in this user so we can simply set uh one
more forward slash
uh curly brackets and before the clay
brackets a dollar for rendering a
variable like an id
like a dynamic id now it will work it
refresh the page
type sanjeet here
now click update
open the console let's check what we are
getting
see we are reading this object here and
the name has been changed to sanjeet for
the id number one
invest the page
refresh the page
and it will be changed sanjit is now at
the first position
in this api
endpoint as well in the mock api i mean
so let's see sanji is now here at the
place of nishant
we can do the same for others like we
can add
mayank here and click uday
this will be changed to mayank
refresh the page
mine will be on third number
refresh refresh refresh
what's wrong
refresh this
i think netflix problem is now it's
herman
so that was
about updating data so let me write some
comments here for clarification
this one is post request
request this one is
this one is
put request
put means updating data
request
the fourth one or this one is called
let's say select comment let's comment
it and then use the vector under the
user vector
so this will be
get request
and the last one is left which is called
delete so let's do that as well
create one more button for this
we will
add a delete text here for the button
label
and
in the place of update data we will use
the delete function
so just copy this update for update data
function and
duplicate it
delete data this will be called
delete
data
everything will be the same but we don't
have to use
the second parameter
we don't have to send the data we simply
have to delete this
let me now map the but function to this
button
and it will work
let's try
fine this is a delete method
let me write
delete
method
method
now click delete in any one of them like
sales
if we refresh
charge won't be here but it is here
let me check this
okay we have okay this should be not put
delete method we have to add it here
delete for delete
now let's try click delete in challenge
click here in the api endpoint page
and see we don't have the challenge name
here anymore
we have nisha we have sanjit
we can also do one more thing here we
can simply call
this user workbook or this get function
in another function
to render the updated data after
deletion
that's not for the scope or let's do
that as well
let me create one more function here
sponsored
get
data
and all the things here and simply we
will call
this git data function here
get data
and
same function we will call here when we
delete
that way this delete function maybe get
called
and it will delete or it will refresh
the page
with the updated data click mayank
okay not deleted
let's try
okay so now we're deleted
we have only sanjeet and shake
click sanjit delete button here
it won't be anymore fine
so that was
all the four requests
let me copy and
party cut and paste to get here
so we have seen
post put
patch and delete
i mean post
get
put and delete the patch works the same
way as
put where does it put here
but
fine
so what can we do
else fine
in the get request you see where is it
here we have we are getting all the data
so let me add one more called nishant
click post data
now it refresh
this will be here
let me add one more called uda
postdata
it will be here as well
but in the documentation you will see
let me open new resource
we have two things forget we can either
get one data
or we can get all data so currently
we're adding all the data let's try to
get one data
so in the users we can simply pass
the id
which is let's say
we have four for a bit check so we don't
use this just add four
four now we will only see for a mishake
but the problem is we will get an object
not an array
so we can console.log this to check
open the console and refresh
see now we are getting
a object of abhishek like this
fine so that was
gate by id and directly get for all
with no id param path params
so that's all for now and that was all
about axios or api requests
i mean axios api request that's fine
so
what is the bouncing
if we search it on google let's say what
we get the
bouncing
it simply means delaying a function in
javascript or
like yes in javascript
basically
so see the bouncing instruments okay not
this it's chemistry in
javascript
yes this one
it is written here that
the bouncing in javascript is a practice
used to improve browser performance
there might be some functionality in a
web page which regula
okay we don't need this it simply means
telling a function
where do i find a correct
definition
a debounce function makes your code only
triggered once as per user input yes
this is correct
or if you want a more clear explanation
okay let me open
this
my channel or my page and free code camp
here
fine there are some heavy tasks in
software development like calling an api
so here we have an api endpoint
suppose
the api
searches a list of users and we cannot
or can't afford to fire it too often
we want to search it only when we have
typed the whole query or whole input
so
let's implement this
in react
we will create a function const let's
say
okay we have to create a function so
let's say um
what can we say
search
pin
and here i have a api that is that will
search
the pin code or like location details
according to the pin code
we also have axios installed so let's
export xcos for import xeos
import seos from axio
here we will make the api call so
xcos.get we will use get method
then we will pass this pin api here
endpoint
let's also create one input tag
of placeholder
enter your
pin
code
so it's done
and it's here
let me zoom this too much okay fine
we have this input
fine
but let's do one more thing here
let's bring it down so we have to just
copy or cut this paste it in app
or and then remove everything else
that we don't need
and it's here also remove the background
color because that also we don't need
we have enter your pin code
now this function
will run when we type something in the
pin code input
this input we can say on change event
we can call this starchmen input
then we have to pass the query
so we can say event here
it will take
event
let's do this
let's just pass the target
and value directly
now this will take an event
here
and it will pass event dot target dot
value
let's take the value here
and
and and and and and we have to append
the
value here in this pin api
so
we will do a question mark
um
wait a second
let's do this yes
it will append the value like this so we
can say console
dot log it responds res
and
save if it fails we will simply catch it
cache
to get the error if any in the console
console.log
error
we have one extra
market let's try this open the console
oh sorry not to console let's open the
network tab first
let me
do it like this
close this
click settings here how do i remove this
yes
yes yes click settings
but what about this
we can't clear disable cache no
just
click this button it will not okay just
bring it
upwards a little bit
now let's type the pin code
see
we can
see the response here
it's returning us
this
and it's a bending the pin code to this
api
using this value
so in the preview in response we are
getting the post offices
so let's filter it out
now if you now if you know if
you now know the api call is getting
called properly
so let's refresh and try once more add
the pin code
okay undefined what about address
let's try once more eight zero zero zero
zero one
one more zero extra i need to remove
that
open this response we have to keep the
data
for rds dot data
and what's inside the data
zeroth index we have to filter zero
index
dot post office
so that's not important the data we are
getting the data is not important the
important is
how we are reading the data so let's say
if you are if you open the network tab
clear it out everything
type your pin code let's say eight zero
zero zero zero one
so
let's start let's say you type the pin
code six or five times
you have to just
how does
how will it expand
okay so we called api
like six times
because we have six numbers here
so the api call has been called six
times
each with a different response and
request
so to avoid that we use debouncing and
if you use the bouncing
what will happen is the api call will be
called only once
and this whole data this whole query
will be sent at once
because currently if you see
we are sending 8 then 8 0 then 800 8 000
and then so on till the last letter
so that's not preferable
that causes abuse of the api and
trust me you don't want that
so what we can do is we can just
refresh the page
let's implement the balancing now so for
the debouncing function we need a method
which is called useful from react
so let's import it import
use effect
from react
also it's fine here but we need one more
thing called states
so we will import use state hook
and we will create one state so cost
let's say pin and set pin
now if you type the pin it will be set
inside
this pin state using set pin method
now let's create the hook of user effect
all these things we have to do
then it's simple
now
we have a dependency array
so if we put the pin here or the state
here this use effect hook will run
and it will call anything that's inside
it
when
like it will call everything inside it
when the value changes
so we will do this
it will create a set timer function
inside
this
user vector we will do
const set
or search pin let's do this
equal to
we will use set timeout
set timeout
or let's do set search pin or let's call
the function
the bouncing
point we are creating a function called
bouncing okay yes
then we have to move this whole thing
inside the set amount function but one
more thing before moving it inside
this takes the function that it will
call
and the interval so let's say we want to
call the api after two seconds of typing
so when we type
and let's type eight four zeros and one
the moment we finish typing one at the
last
after two seconds this function will run
after tapping two seconds
i will show you
so in the balancing we have set timeout
here
let's cut
the xus api called and we don't need it
here
remove this
so
the value becomes the pin now
because we have the state here
so pin api plus the pin it will append
the pinning code to the api at the last
fine and then we'll display the data
so it's done the bouncing now we have to
call the function
so to call the function
we can simply set
we can simply do
this
so
how to call the function
let's do this so we will do return
and inside this return we will do
but wait a second okay um how to do this
is in the return we will do this
clear timeout
player timeout and we will pass this
demonstrating function
so let's see if it works or not
now what will happen is if we type in
the pin code text the pin will change
and this function will run
but it will only run when
we type the last letter
and then after two seconds this api call
will be displayed
so now let's check clear the console
now let's type the pin code eight zero
zero zero zero one
let's check
see it works
after like two seconds
we are getting this
call here api call with the data that is
present in the database
all this data
let's try one more clear it out
let's try
six zero zero zero zero one
see
now we are writing the data of chennai
because
this input of 6
this is the pin code of like from
chennai i think
if we
add 5 it will fetch
one more set of data
after 2 seconds
fine
so that's how the bouncing works in
react
we have two components here home and
profile
both at the same level
in the home we are passing a name
a state called name
in the profile we are passing the
function to set the state of set name
in the profile we have a button
that will change the name to there when
clicked
then it will like if we change the name
it will be passed here
and the name will be passed in the home
component like this
so if you click the name change the name
button
the name will change to that like this
let's
remove the profile we don't need that
all right fine
change the name the name is there so
basically we have a app that changes
name
using two components
it is changing in profile
using a button
and it's getting displayed in the home
component
so where in the both components we are
passing name and set name as props
here we are saving it and declaring it
but
this can cause
a lot of like clumsy code
and it also causes one thing which is
called prop delay
for example let's say we have a
component home in the app.js
in the home we are calling another
component as its child
in that child component like lets child1
we are calling
subchild1 then we have to pass the name
all over
to avoid that we use something called
context api in react
so let's see how it works
so the first step is we have to create a
context here
so let's do that let's create a folder
first called
context
context
in the folder let's create a file called
global context global
global
context.s
a javascript file
let's import something called create
context
this will be used to create a context
in the global context.js file
let's create a const let's say
let's say let's say let's say
user data
let's create the context using this
then we have to
pass this create context and an empty
object here
this user data will be our global object
or global state
so we will do an export here if you want
to use this user data in other
components
basically we will import the user data
in this component of app.js
so import
create not create context
user data
from
context context
and global context
so now this chooser data will be
imported from here
we have to wrap
the both components in the user data
like this
let's make the name as capital let's
make it an snu
same here
and here save this then this
fine
then
we don't need to like have our self
closing tag yet
we have to wrap our components in this
user data tag
like this
so we are wrapping our home component
and profile component
in
user data
fine
it was second this was the second step
the next thing we have to do is we have
to
add a provider so we will add dot
provider
provider means we are sending data
we have to do it in the both opening and
posing tags like this
it's done it's working perfectly
now let's pass the data or the functions
let's say we have to pass some value
we have to pass the value using this
value prop
let's pass the name here
because we want to pass the name and set
name as well
if we are adding the value here we don't
have to add this here
it will be automatically
propagated to both components wrapped in
user context
i mean this is a data provider
so it's done third step
now let's come into the global context
okay not in global context in let's say
home.js
fine we don't need to get this from here
remove this and this as well
so don't save it because you will get an
error because name is not defined yet
so now let's get data
because here we are sending data to home
and profile
the both name and set name
so this both will be available in
home.js as well as in profile.js
components
so let's now get data that we're sending
so we will import the same thing which
is
use context from
react
also we have to import
the context name which is our data data
so we will say import
user data
from
profile not profile two steps back
context
and global context save this
wait a second user data fine we are
doing it right
okay
so in here
we don't have the set name yet
wait a second here we don't have the set
name
or name yet
so to get the name we will simply
destructure it
to restructure it we will do
const
name equals to
okay not like this we have this
structure so we can say
let
name
equals to
we will have to use
use context hook and have to pass
the context name which is user data user
data
like this
now it will work
the same thing we have to do inside
profile.js
but
we will have to get
this thing
set name not the name because we are
setting it using the function of sick
name
also import these two things here
and save enter and save
now this should work
now click change the name
and it should work
click it
and see
the name is with that
if you make it to something else like a
base shake
and click it again
it will change the name to a bishop
and that's how
the use context hook or context api
works in react
so it's a simple example but you can
like
do a lot of things with this oh sorry
for example
let's see we had one more component here
called
settings
dot js
make it functional component
let's import settings component in
home.js
like this
import
settings
let's render it out here
also let me make it an h1 tag
to display it
properly
save
so it's here
so let's say we want to pass the name as
props
so it is in the home component yes we
have to pass
if we are using props we have to pass
like
this
like this i mean
then
we have to
come to home.js
we have to destructure it like this
then again we have to pass the name
again
name as
name
then we have to get it again here so
it's a lengthy process
and this thing passing the state
as props is called prop drilling
so it's coming from
app.js to home component it's coming
from home to settings and so on
so basically we don't need to do it here
so remove this
remove
top
here
and remove this from here
suppose we want to access the name here
as well we will do the same thing
we will import these things
let me remove it from here as well
we will import these two things like use
context and user data come into settings
and we have to change the route for this
yes it's the same route we don't have to
change it fine
let's
do this thing and structure the context
now we can print the settings
or simply the name here a b shape
let's change a little bit
a little bit say
we have to pass one more state let's say
const
active and or let's say age
let's pass the agent settings component
set age
use state let's say 51
is a number
so
let's pass the edge as context here
in the provider
it's passed as a value
let's also get the settings but wait a
second
this shouldn't we don't have to do it
here
it's wrong
so
okay i mean if we want the state in the
settings we can pass it here
in the value
in the provider
then let's come to the settings page
we will create one more
we will structure it
and we will do
this what is that age
age
let's print the edge
let's try this
see what we get see now we are reading
the edge as well
because we are passing the h as the
global context here in the provider
so that's all and that's how it works
our use context api
so let's see the difference between
class and class names in react
we are using a class component here
of class of app
let's add some styling in m.css
so we use the class keyword to
add a styling to our
html elements
or in our case we have jsx in react not
html
so we have an header here a class of
header
with a red color
and this border
in the css file
now let's merge them
so we will say h1 class
this header
because that's how we do in html right
it's working also you see
we have a red color
text fh1 with the black border around it
but the problem is
we are using two class keywords here
one is for creating the class
that encapsulates or like
it covers all these things
like render return and all
and in the return we are using one more
class called this
for
rendering the css
if you open the console
what we will see is an error
that says invalid term property
determine class name
because
we cannot use class two times because
it's a reserved keyword that is used to
create a class
in
react or in javascript
so if we search class in javascript we
will see the same thing
classes are used to create a class
just like this
so instead of the class we can use class
name
and it will work fine it will look the
same way
and we don't have the error now if you
check
we won't have it
see no errors here
refresh and save
so that's how or that's why we use
class
name
instead of class
let me show the same in function
component
make an h1
here that says something like
a second h1
that says hello
now let me import css here
import
app
dot
tss save it
now let's use class here
class
equals to wait
header
it will reflect here
but you will see the error that we got
previously in class component
that class name is an invalid dom
property
need mean last name
so the same thing is here
so
to fix this error or warning we can say
class name here
and it will work the same way
but with no errors
if you open the console let's see what
we have we have no errors
of using this class
so that's how or that's why we use class
name instead of class keyword in react
first of all let me explain all this
code here
we are having two components users and
photos sorry posts we are calling this
both in app.js like this we are
reporting this and calling this in this
lift class name
in the users we are fetching all these
users here
from jsonpress folder
all the users
and we are mapping it through
this array and returning the name we
have users
similarly we have the posts
we have having an array of post the
state we have
a function to get all the posts use the
fact hook
and
the same thing we are returning
the user title from the posts array
fine we also have h2 here and we have
this h2
so the basic thing to know here is
the both components users dot js and
post dot js they are same i mean the
logic is same
for example we have same state
we have the array state i mean
only the name is different we have this
gate posts and get users function the
functionalities are same
we are calling fetch api using the api
in point and returning response then we
are
setting inside the state
then in the use effect hook we have it
here
we are calling the function then we are
returning the mapped array like this
so
we have two components users and posts
we have to create
let's create a hierarchical component
that will solve our problem
for example we don't have to use
the function two times here
we will write the logic only once it
will run in the both components
it will take some parameter and it will
run
same way it will be done here
so let's see how to prove that in the
react component
so now what we have to do is we have to
create a file here
in the source folder called
higher
order
dot js
so make it a functional component like
this
in this return i mean in the function of
higher order it will return one more
return
or one more thing we will return a
function
so return function let's say hoc
in the host we will put this
fine
it's done remove this as well
and
fine
so first
now what we have to do is we have to
remove
this
default export from here
and do this
let me import the component of higher
order
so import
this component
and simply
do this const
users
comp
equals to
higher order
then we will pass
this user's component
first let's pass the component
title just users
not the component
so
we have to export this as well so export
default
users com
user comp or better make it users com
save it
also remove the posts from here
save it save it save it
so here's comp is here
fine
we are passing the title so let's get
the title
in this component
so we can say title
in this div
we will simply make an h2
and we will render out the title
we can see we will see post sorry users
now
as the title layer if you make it this
it will change dynamically
let's do the same for posts
we don't need all this now remove this
effects
this
okay we don't we need this but later
but here what we will do is see we are
passing
we are doing this so let's do it here as
well
remove this
populist paste this
make this as posts make this as
posts
comp and quote it
defaultly
nowadays fresh we will not see it here
because we are not importing this
component here so import it
okay higher it is not undefined let's
define it or import it
go down to try it so tight
refresh
we will see posts but we are not seeing
here why
we can not see posts
because there are personal
find
refresh
why cannot we see posts
users com
put this
goes
export this
higher order post okay
call it here as well fine
now it's working you can see the title
say it successfully
now let's
just pause this function
let me bring it here first we have users
and posts
so we have to just cut all the function
and the state we don't need it here
we just need this user's mapping here
and here
we have to paste here
the paste and then import
the use state hook and use effect hook
simply like this
change the users to data
so it will be done here and
here change the set user to set data
and change it here
then third thing to change
is the function name this should be not
get users get data
change it here save all these things
fine
just like we passed the title
we have to pass
the component name called users
so we don't need the s2 of users here
and they post save
and save so just pass
this users here
as
arguments and here we will pass the
function of posts
we are passing two things here pose as a
string and a
function here as well users as a string
and users as a function
so here we don't need
state and effects so remove it
so we are passing it here
so we have to receive it as well now so
we will day we will say
component
so
we will call it as a component
so for example
let's say we had it here
how do we call it we can call it using
this
save
and refresh the page
we will see nothing
because nothing is here in the div in
the return
so we can add an h1 in the users and say
hello from users
the same thing we can do in posts so
let's make it an h2 not h1 we can say
hello
from posts
here we are using adding users and here
posts
and we can see it here successfully
but
what about the data how will we pass the
data to show it here
it's very simple just pass it as props
in the component like this
let me receive it as props
the way we do it and
we can uncomment this
then we can say data dot slides
this map
then we can see all this data
which is
user names for the component of posts
same thing can be done
so
uncomment and make the posts
wait sorry data. data.slice
dot map and all
refresh the page
refresh and we can see all these things
but see
we are not seeing
the title of the post posts because
we have none
instead of title we have this
which is called sorry instead of
with a secondary slice title we should
get it here
but we are not
title
wait a second
yes we're not getting title because
we don't have title
in the users
because
see
we are just calling the users
so if you make this says name we should
see all the names
so same api is called
for the both components users and posts
so to change it we will do this
so to change it how can we change it
we will pass the third thing here in the
component of higher order
this will be
a string called
the last word of the api call for
example we have the users
so we have to pass this users
in the posts we have to pass sorry pass
posts
now it will come up here
let's say
let's say let's say the source
or response
not response what is the better name for
this we can say request
so pass the request here
dynamically so request
and add a toilet to make it dynamic
now we will don't we will not see the
posts because
it's dynamic
we can only see the post sorry let me
explain why
we are not seeing posts
because we are mapping the data
this data
user's data which has no
name in it
but sorry we are not mapping the data we
are mapping these posts
which has
no users in it it has title instead
so we can say user title
and it will be here
see
we have this
posts
and we have this users
let me differentiate or make an
hr tag between them
a horizontal line
so here we have posts we have users
sorry we have users here and post here
all done
with a single component called higher
order
so
we are calling the component in both
components i mean we are calling the
higher order component in users
component
and main posts
in the users we are passing the title
the component function
and the api last endpoint
like
this users
or posts see
both
in both we are doing this
it is coming in this component as title
as title c the user is the title the
component
all the data component and the request
is this request
the api last word
i don't know what is called because i'm
not
i'm very tired right now to think fine
so we have request here
so it's fetching the data according to
request according to the
posts or users
fine
then it's also getting stored inside
this data that's been stored inside a
data state
this is the component that we're
rendering
and in the component we're passing the
data as props
it's coming here as data and then we are
mapping it successfully in both
components
users and posts
so it's like a full circle
we are calling the higher order
component here
then exporting the component here
it's coming here all these things were
passing
then again
it's getting called like a function here
we are having a state which contains all
the data
as per the api call
we are passing the component
again here with the data
and now it's coming here and it's
getting mapped
so that's how or that's what is a
hierarchy component in react and how to
use it
so what is lazy loading
so lazy loading simply means to load a
component when we really need it
for example let's say we have a file
that's too big
like this file so many text here letters
or a project
with so many components like a admin
panel or a
user management portal so in those cases
when the file or project structure is
big
we can use lazy loading to decrease
the load time and increase the
performance of the app
so let me show you the current
performance of
these two components
let me comment
this and save let me refresh
and bring this back
so if we refresh it once more
let me
change this network close radio to no
throttling
refresh it
so
the bundle size is four over nine
kilobytes
default is in loading so i have already
wrote it here these commands
so bundles are this for 4.9 kilobytes
and the time is 1 3
5
ms milliseconds
now let's check the load time and the
size after lazy loading
to implement lazy loading we will just
do this
const let's say lorem
the component name
then we will use react
dot lazy
l should be small
followed by a fallback function callback
function sorry
not fallback callback
in the callback we will simply import
the component path so for lorem it's
lorem
lauren lauren lauren lauren
then const
home equals to react
dot lazy
we will add the path for home this will
be
aim not import what was that yes import
the home
route
h4mb
comment the
routes before reloading save
now let's check refresh the page
now in the bundle the size is
375
ms
and
the load time is
191 milliseconds which is
wait a sec
size 191 milliseconds that's much
okay
i think we recorded it wrong so let's
comment this
and bring back this
the original imports
we refresh the page
in bundle.js
we have 4.9 kilobytes
and one for one millisecond
one four one save
now comment these two
and bring back
the
lazy loaded routes
refresh
in the bundle it's three seven five
three seven five yes
okay three seven five and
wait wait wait wait wait we move remove
remove remove
and one three one so it's smaller than
the
default loading imports
so see it differs
wait a second bundle.js it's 375
kilobytes not ms
kb
small k in big b
like this
so
that's lazy loading
that decreases the load time and
increases performance
i mean it's not much
but for a larger application
it will be dramatic
and it will drastically improve
the performance
if we use lazy loading
so
what if we make the network slow like
through slow 3g refresh the page
it will load very slowly and in our case
if we load it
let us load it open the
network tab load it
it will be very slow and we will see
this blank screen
when we are loading the components
how to fix that
so we use something called suspense from
react
so let's do this
we can import suspense from react
and
then wrap the components in suspense
save
okay the suspense suspense will take a
fallback
this one is a callback and it's a
fallback
so it is rhyming equals to
we have to add
the component that will load here
so we can either add direct
jsx like a div
and anything inside it
that says
loading
please
p l e s e wait
save
now if you refresh
and close this you will see something
called
loading please wait
for a small time
for a brief moment of time see it's
still here i don't know how to decrease
the network speed
uh before this let's add custom
throttling custom profile
let's say
profile name
is vvs
and this is
3
k b i t
slash s
what is the problem number one must be
number one zero two
ten
kilo bytes i think between zero to ten
let's make it ten
you cancel this
refresh this let's try offline
refresh the page
no internet okay that's something else
fine
so let's try slow 3g
once more
and you will see a loading text here
loading please wait
for a short moment of time
so that's how we do suspense in react
or else if you don't want to use this
div directly
you can simply import a component
so i have one component here called
loader
let's import it so input loader
from one step back loader
and just
add the
loader in the fallback
callback callback
refresh now you will see the loader
again
see
so let's try to increase the text
a little bit more
let's see what happens
let's paste it a bunch of times in
app.js
but in home.js
so just
paste it keep pasting it
you don't need github
keep pasting it and save
now it
is
now bigger
we don't need to format it
so refresh
now the loading text will take some time
before it disappears
so we can call the home once more and
once more and once more
now let's check what we have
now we see the loading text you see
please wait and the loading will come
when
the
component is loading
when the vl is loading the component
so that's about lazy routing and react
and how it works
as you see here
we have a function called get users
that's getting the users from this api
call
we are simply calling the
function to get the users
fine
but let's suppose a case where
this api call we have to do
in 10 different files or like 50
different files or components
so we have to repeat this function all
over directly we have to
make an api call to this api endpoint
using fetch api xeos
then call this then post it and put it
inside by use effect look like this
but that's not proper
so in this case we will create a helper
function
so let's create a folder called
helpers
and in the folder let's create a file
called
get
users or get all users
dot js
copy this function const get users
and add it here
make it export
and
we don't need this console
we will simply return this function
c
and that's all
for now for the
helper function
now we have a helper function to get the
users from this api call
and we can call it in any file we want
and that made our things easy
so now now let's import this
function
we can say get users
from
helpers slash get all users
and we are done
but a few things before that
we have to return it in a led variable
so this is returning some value
the data after fetching the results all
these 10 array items
so we have to store it inside a variable
called data
then we can simply console.log
this data and if we refresh the page
we will get this promise
so we have to create another function
we can use async of it here but it's not
proper
so make a function called const
get users helper
it will be an arrow function like this
move these two things or cut things here
and then call it here
it will still be a promise
so we have to use the async function
make it as sync
and get users will be await
now let's check so refresh the page
now we can get all the data here
correctly without calling any api in our
main file
so that's make
our app.js or any component in which we
help use the helper function clean and
easy to use and understand
so the logic is separate from here and
the ui is separate
now let's take one more example
let me create one more helper function
here
which will be called add to dot js
this will add to numbers
so we'll do export const let's say add
nums
make it an arrow function again
okay what i am doing equals to this
syntax
then in this function we will simply
turn
the a plus b so this a plus b we have to
get it somewhere from somewhere
so we will get it from arguments
then if we
call the function we have to pass a and
b here
so copy this function name add nums
come here
we can simply call the function
add nums
from
helpers
slash
add to
so
we can call the function so let's create
one more
so let's say const
add to
nums
helper
then we can simply call
this function like this
then let's add a button here
say add
and on the button we have an online
event we can have
and this function
call
now it will
return this
but we have to store it in some variable
so we can select sum equals to this
and
we can simply
console this sum
console.log sum
now click the button okay we can just
comment this data console here
now
add click add
we will see
nnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnn
n means not a number
because we are not passing any arguments
or parameters because it's getting true
so we can pass two numbers directly say
two and three
and now if we click add
we give we will get five here
in line number fourteen in app.js file
so
that was function a function to add two
numbers using a helper function
suppose we want to add one more function
here called
sum so we had some already we can say
const
multiply
so we can do return
a multiplied by b
it will also take two things because c
and b are not defined
in add to
wait a second
in add to
yes it's not defined
so we have to define it
then it will multiply and return us back
the multiplied number
so here we can do or
simply import it first
so it's multiply the function name
and let's measure make it multiply nums
so copy this function name and add it
here input it first
so we have the sum here
we can also have let's let
multipulse equals to
multiply sums and let's add two numbers
two and four
then we can console
the same thing
so what is the problem multiply nums
was not found in helpers add to save
this then it will work
let's add one more button
for multiplication but we can use it as
also so if we click we will get sum and
multiplied numbers
so 5
2 plus 3 5 and 2 into 4 equal to 8
i think i'm correct
so that's
so
let me show you one last thing here
we are calling this get users helper
function
i mean we are having a function of get
users helpers
in this we are calling get users this
function
we can pass
a param here as well
so for example
if you see we have something like
posts comments albums all things
so let's try to add the posts here
pasta
variable called posts
i mean not a variable a string
it will come
in the get users function
and we can receive the users
we can receive it as
params
or parameter
then
let me convert this into string literals
here
then we can simply
replace user with the param
so if we pass anything
here in this function of get users it
will come up here
it will append to the api endpoint and
it will call so now i will get all the
posts
refresh
comment uncomment this data
and we are getting all the hundred posts
see
if you pass to do's we will get to do's
so let's pass to do's
so now it became just it just it became
dynamic
it just became dynamic
yes
now if it is refresh the page it will be
to do's
200
this
we can check the network tab so let's
open network
refresh
let me filter it to xhr and fetch api
let me turn
it network
all settings where is the filter
i think settings
slow 3g to
fast or no throttling
now
you will see we are reading to do there
if you open headers this will be to do's
if you make it as photos we will see
photos
in the console it refresh
and we're reading photos
so it just became dynamic
so that is heart or that is what is a
helper function in react and how to use
it
so as you see here
i have an object a family tree which
contains children's
for example this john
it's a grandfather
and it contains these children called
mary
arthur and dolores
it has his children
so we're mapping the children from this
this
array
yes so click this john
it will show the name of history
children's
but this can become hectic if we have
children inside children inside children
like this that right that's right
so see you have children inside children
and it can go on and on and on
in that case we cannot get
or we cannot
map each and every child
statically like this we are doing right
here we have to automate the process so
that it maps itself
so in that case we will use recursion
so that the family function or component
calls itself when it comes to mapping
so let's do that we will call this
family function again
in the time of mapping
so
we will pass
the same prop here family tree but in
this case it will be child
so for example let's say we are mapping
this children first children
it's returning us this thing
and the child children inside it
if it is true it will pass it up here
again and it will like
break it like it's going up here
so let's pass
the family tree
prop as child
so if it has a children
array
it will map it up if it is not have an
array it will skip it
so that's the power of recursion
now let's try this
click john
it's open
mary add serendoratus it's opening this
then click the author it will open up
because arthur has
the children diary
these two
now click marry it will not open up
because mary has no children
now let's go into dollars
same dollars has no children
but in this arthur we have lillian billy
if you click lily it will have two
children because then it will open up
but hank and henry have no children so
it will not open up
then again same with billy it will not
open up
so in a same way in a similar manner
if the child if the child have some
children
it will open up or else it will not open
up
so that's recursion in react and how to
use it
so in this video let's see a question
that says write a function which takes
an array of multiple functions
and
executes them one by one in left to
right manner
and it has been asked by the matter
in their intervention or questions
so let's try to tackle this question
our approach should be simple
we will create an array first so let's
create an array of this const
fn array
and it will be a
array yes
so step one that was
and inside we will have some functions
so it says
it takes an error sorry array of
multiple functions
so let's create multiple functions so
let's function key what we need
fn
that's how we write a function
let's return
return
a plus b
let's write the params here
fine
we have function to add two numbers
let's repeat it three times
this will be subtract so minus
multiplication and this one should be
division
so we have an array of four functions
so this part is done
now let's execute it
so let's create a function
a main function that it says in the
question so write a main function
so const
main
fn
we can make this an arrow function
inside this we can call
this
array using map method simply
but first we have to call this function
in this effect as well
if you want to run it on the page mounts
on the page mount
sorry not
yes not here here sorry sorry here we
have to write
so we will simply map
this
different array so we can say map to get
all the functions inside directly
it takes a parameter called fn
and we can simply return
this fn function
now let's store the data inside once
variable because it's returning it so
console.
okay let's do this let's say let
data
or let's say relate result
so whatever we get from all these
function
executions we will get inside this
result the data will get inside this
result so we will get addition
subtraction multiplication division all
these
and then we can simply console it to
check in the console
so what is that
let's open the console and check what we
are getting right now it will be an
error
we are getting this array yes it's an
error because all the four items are
giving nine
because we're not passing
this
values which is a and b so let's pass
two and three
so refresh
now we are getting this so
2 and 3 we are passing so this will be
5
minus 1 because 2 minus 3 equals to
minus 1
this should be 6 because multiplication
and this should be
this
0.6665
we can make this as 4 or 6 and 3
then we will get this
9 because we're writing them
3 we are subtracting them
18 multiplication and 2s division
so that was how we do it in an array
but we have one more option here to do
this
not in an array but in an added object
so let me comment this and wrap this in
an object
like this
we will make
an add value here add key now this
additive add this add will run
when the function is running
i mean this add will run
when we call the ad
so why don't we make this as something
else called
or make this function as add
and this should be
a
simple key name which will be function
now we have the add function
similarly let's repeat it
multiple times
okay not this
let's repeat
let's make it minus
multiplication
and
division
division
now this should be
divide
this should be what can we call it
multiply
or multiply multiply yes
they should be
subtract
now we have now four different functions
add subtract multiply and divide
save we can remove this but let's leave
it
now we will call fn.fn because
we have a key name here in this object
because right now it will give an error
if you refresh the page
cannot try properties sorry fn is not a
function
so i will do fn dot
fn and that will work now
the same way refresh
and we are writing all the four items
after subtract after addition or sum
subtraction division and multiplication
so in both cases we can do it
so
i think that's all the question
has been solved
we have a function
that takes array of multiple functions
and executes them one by one left to
right
so left right means from top to bottom
if you are saying this
formatted code so add is that left
then second left third left and fourth
left
so that was how we do it and it's done
so let's say custom hook is a service
we can say like in angular we have
services
the same way we can have a custom hook
but with more
functionalities
so let's try to create a custom hook
here that will call these two apis
we will need a file here called let's
create a file called
hooks
in the file let's create a sorry in a
folder let's let's create a file called
use
json
or use yes
json
place holder
so if you want to create a hook you will
use the name
with hugos jsonpress filter like this
here we will create
these two things so let's
copy and or cut and paste it here
save
now what we have to do is we have to
just create and function like this
like this function app
so we'll do function
let's say
use data
use data
it will be in function like the app.js
inside we will see we have these things
all these use effect hooks and states
so see we are having these two states
and we are using it here so let's create
this
in our this hook
inside this function
yes so paste it and save but we need to
use state from react so let's import it
import
use state from
react
save
and these two functions
we also need inside this use data
at the last we need to export this so
export
default
this use data work
and we are done
not done almost done
we have two states use
users and posts and we're calling the
api
we will note here that we will we also
have this use effect hook so
we need this here
in order to run these two hooks
these two methods i mean get users and
get posts so let's import this as well
here so use
effect
and it's done
fine so save this file but we will get
an error because we don't have the users
here
these states we don't have here
so let's return them
from this
component
just like we returned
some jsx here
this we will return it here so we can
say
in curly bracket we will do
users comma posts
and that's all
so that's how that is our custom hook to
fetch the users and posts
from this apis
but we have to call this new hook into
our app.js so let's do it we can import
use data from this address
this
navigation address
then we can restructure the data here we
can select
users and comma posts
equals to use not sorry note you use
data yes we have to this
and it will work it will fetch the data
that it was fetching previously
so here now i have a hook
that fetches the users and
get posts and its loads on the
page load or page mount
so basically we're doing this we are
getting the posts and users from these
apis
and loading them on page mount
which is in our custom home
so we can use it anywhere we want
because
we don't need this here remove it fine
yes we can use it any way we want
in our file or project or component
or our react app
so that was all about how to create a
custom hook
for a custom
singular group
so let's take an example first of a
real-life promise
that says
i promised someone to be my friend
on one condition that i give him a
chocolate every day
if i fail to give him a chocolate even
on our day or a single day or one day
he will break the promise and he will
not be my friend
now let's implement this in react
so what we will do is we can create a
let friend
function
inside we will have a syntax for promise
which will say
new promise
it will take two things which is resolve
and reject
so if the promise is complete done
it will be dissolved
or else if it fails it will be rejected
now let's create a condition for promise
so let's create a variable first so let
is chocolate
every day
if it is true
only then the promise will resolve
so we have to do this
so if this is true is chocolate every
day
if this is true
we will call
this
resolve and we will pass
some params which will say
promise
resolved
if it fails
so it means if this variable is false is
chocolate every day
we will reject it we can say reject
and a message called
promise
broken
so that's done
now we have to call this function called
trend
so we can do it like this so a friend
function
then we will use then block
so then for resolve statement
which will return as a response
if it is successful
so in this then log we will call this
response and we can simply console.log
this response
and we will get this message here
promise result
but if it fails we have to call a catch
block
which says an error
or let's make this simply as dissolve
to simplify things and this one has
reject
clg
digit
now open the console and let's see what
we are getting in the console
refresh
okay something is wrong trend is not a
function
so what can we do here
let friend okay fine make it as const
then it will work
okay the problem is this is not a
function so let me clear this
save and let me refresh the page now it
will work
so promise resolve because
we are resolving the promise it's true
then it's returning this thing
or else if it fails it will return this
so make it as
false because
we fail to give chocolate every day
so it's broken
we can add a customizer here as well
like this so we can say or just wrap it
in a
template little string
and we can add our text
no
dot add here do i dot here and say no
more
body not here
do it here
like this that will say
no more
f r i e n d ship
no more friendship
and now i will get the extended message
here with
this promised broken message
no more friendship
so that was
promising react
now let's take one more example for
thomas here
in this promise one it is a function and
it's getting a parameter called prime
one
if the parameter may pass its nissan
it resolve else it will reject
in the second function we are passing
param2
and if param is promised resolved this
resolve text
it will be resolved and print this or
else this
basically we will link these promises
together
in a chain so we can call the promise
one first so say promise one
we will pass some parents let's say
nishant
then it will resolve because the
parabola is nishant then as per
condition it will dissolve
it will return us some message
in the then block say
response
we can control this response and let's
see what we get
let's also call the function in this
effect
to run when the page mounts
so open the console
it is a phrasal page
we are saying promise resolve text
line number 27 because
the promise has been resolved
and now see this promise 2 takes a param
2
and if it is equal to this problem is
resolved
it will resolve this
else it will reject this
so we have to chain one more than here
say then
and here we can say uh
response again
response
or we can say f response for first
response and s response
for second response
then we can console dot log
this s response
but we are not calling this function
if we save and run it will be undefined
because the function is not getting
called and this is null or undefined
so we have to call promise 2 here and we
have to pass this f response here
so let's do it
and pass
this f response
now it will work refresh the page
we will see
promise resolved and undefined wait s
response
is
getting passed here
promise resolved
the text is right
let me add one more block called l or
catch error block
so the catch if it isn't any error
then we can say
err error
and
console.log
this error
now we are reading this promise resolved
again and undefined
but we shouldn't get this
then
s response
we are calling this promise to
okay the problem is we have to return
this function
not simply call it like this it will not
work so return promise to an f response
now i will get these two both
so let me
console it or just go back
and return this function
now refresh it once
we will get promise resolved and sean is
a good boy
so basically we are getting first
response
and second response
if we make this
promise rejected here or change the text
we will get some errors
you see we are getting promise resolve
from the first response
and sean is still a good boy from this
reject statement
but
if we change
this thing this should be let's say
challenge
so
it will not go inside this then block
because it will directly reject the
first promise
it will directly go inside this error so
if we refresh and save
we will get promise rejected let me
refresh once more we will see promise
rejected
because in the first level we are not
dissolving the promise so it will not
get inside in this block
it would literally go inside this block
and it will reject the promise
so that was promise in react and how to
use it
so now let's look into asynchronic part
in react
so what is the thing of it
it's nothing but
sync tactical sugar on our promises
so what do i mean by that is
let me show you what i mean by that
so in order to make a function
asynchronous we will have to use assign
keyword here
now the function is async
we have to call await now so we have to
call the function now this is promise
one function
so it simplifies the way we write
promises that's all
nothing else
so we will await this function
from this one and await means
everything else in the promise or in
this promisement function
will wait until this function is
finished executing
so let me record the response in a
variable called
response or res
now let me console
this res
let's see what we are getting
we should say nothing or we should
and it's not matching together
so open the console
console we will see promise rejected
because the name is not matching
so let's pass nishant here or make the
param one equal to nishant
now i will see promise result because
it's getting resolved
fine
so it finishes then everything else will
run because we have an event here
now let me call promise to
so let me call promise to using let
res to response to equal to
await promise to and we have to pass
this response here
because it's promise resolved it will it
will come here
and then it will print this
if it dissolves
so we can console.logs second one as
well
which will say ras2
and we can save the file and check
refresh it once and we will see promise
resolved and nishant is a good boy
fine
but we cannot catch errors here but we i
mean if we want to catch errors let's
say we don't pass anything in the
promise to where is it here
let's say you pass something else called
some random text
we will get this message here so we
cannot
add a custom message we want in this
async of it
oh because but we can
so what we have to do is we have to wrap
it in a try clash try catch block so try
all our code will go inside try
that can fail
and then if it fails
you will call catch
like this
is that right do we have to call catch
like this let's think or try
so in the catch we can say console.log
we can say promise
rejected
i think we don't have to use this
save and now let's see yes that works
tom is rejected because we are passing
some random text here
known the text that's here and being
compared to param2
so promise rejected because you know why
if we add res here it will resolve again
sorry
r-e-s
response
refresh
promise resolve and shan is a good boy
so that was
promise and asynchronic
now let me okay let me just copy
this
let me make this
a sync main
thing the name
and add it here
fine
now let me do this copy the function or
the use effect hope together
and go back
to promises
page or where we wrote the promise code
and simply paste it here
wait brothers sends okay
challenge this should be not here
should we make this
yes
let's add the function here
we only need one use effect hook because
we can call
one user factor and two functions
two birds with one stone so we have
promise main
this is the syntax of
promises
this is a syntax of s incoming
async away
so you can decide which one where do you
want to use
if you want to use promise or a think of
it
i prefer think of it because the code is
shorter and simplified
not this then and then in catch
so that's up to you now and that was all
about promises and async await in react
the implementation
so what is code splitting
it says here that most react apps will
have their files bundled
using tools like webpack crawl up or
browser
e5
bundling is the process of following
imported files and merging them into a
single file called a bundle
and it can be loaded on a web page to
load the app at once
so it basically said that
whatever thing we write in our apps
in this project or in this react app
it will be loaded inside a bundle
let me show you that bundle and what is
it open the network tab
and
you will see if you refresh the page
this bundle bundle.js file we cannot
this file let me show you like this
bundle.js which contains everything so
everything will be abundant
even if we are not using the imported
things here
it will still bundle the app.js input
and this
or
even if we use this or even if we want
to load it like this it will bundle
so in this case we can use something
called code splitting in react which is
me which means that
we can create a smaller bundles this
to avoid winding up with a large bundle
it is good to get ahead of the problem
and start splitting your bundle
it is a feature supported by bundles
like webpack and all
which can create multiple bundles
and it can be related loaded dynamically
at runtime
so
one more thing we have here is loading
that i showed in this playlist you can
see the video
but in this we will use dynamic imports
to
code split
and
we can do it like this
so it's it says here that this is
normally import we are using it here
and this one is the
part is it
it was
forward splitted dynamic input
instead of using import here let me
comment it
we have to use it here
so we can do it like this we can say
import
the path which is
math
and we can use a then function or a then
keyword
then it's simply a promise based or uh
what is it yes promise based call
and if you want to learn about this then
you can see my previous videos
on async await and
promises and react
online limitation will be there
so then we can say math
wait a second
then
we can say
math
and here we can say
uh this thing so just copy or cut and
paste
but
let me make this a small math
this math will be a function
that we are getting here
if you console
this math let me comment this sum and
control this math let's see what waiting
let's see what we're getting in the
console
open the console
we will see this module basically a
bundle
now let me bring this back and we can do
math
dot add
and we will pass five and six
okay
and then we can
just do this as well replace add with
this then we can control some
let's say we will get 11.
so it's working you can see
open the network tab now
and refresh the page
we will see a bundle called
src mac.js
chunk
so
this thing in the user facebook
is a dynamic import let me write it here
dynamic
import and it created
import
it created a small chunk
a small bundle
so we can use the bundle to improve
performance
and decrease load time
fine
fine so
let me give you one more example here so
if we refresh the page
this bundle is loading
see
so let's say in a case when we only need
this bundle when we click a button
so we can create a button here first
that says add
let me quickly create a function so
const
sum or let's say const
simply adds
it doesn't matter
add an arrow function this will be
and we will move all this import in here
including this
let me remove user factbook and
this as well
something is wrong use effect also
that's fine
now this function will only run when we
click the button of add
so we can say on click
on click this thing called
add
we have a button here called add let's
click it and see what we're getting
first let me open the network tab
to see if the bundle is loading or not
no we cannot see that math.js bundle
but wait a second how to remove what
happened
what is this
okay it's something else it's step tools
so you see we are not saying this mac to
js bundle
we will see it only if we click the
button of add
see we are seeing it here and it's
getting called
a chunk file a small bundle
so that's how we use dynamic imports in
react to improve
performance
and it is one of the examples of code
fitting in react
we can use react dot is the import lazy
loading i mean
we can use
fallbacks
okay not this we can use this so it's
just
part of the lazy loading
so that's how we do dynamic imports in
react
so first of all we need some data so
let's go over to this website called
jsonplaceholder.com
we will get
some
apis from here that will feature some
data like this to do
or this posts comment and all
so let's make the
api call in the user effect
or let's create a const method const
let's say um
get data
and all of these then the switch api
now let's import the effect
use effect hook
from react
react
like this
fine
but let's replace this to do's with uh
let's say
let's say
users so make users here nmr1 fine
so we can see all the users if we
call it in user facebook and set the
states and do all this so also we need
the state
so let's create it using your state hook
so
user set users equals to users for use
effect and array
now let's set it here
instead of console.log then we have to
call the function in the user book
so render it here
then call the function simply like this
get data
save
now time to map
this users to return the data inside so
we can say users dot
map
let's say
user
then we can return
some j6 that can be a div or a fragment
first
in the fragment let's make h2 of
user not name you will get all the
username here
so if you open the users we have
more things like
username as well so let's render this as
well
we can make an p tag and then we can say
user dot username
what is it username
if
we have the username here
this all
let's make
wait a second let me wrap this in a
div
this user's mapping
then give it a class name of
class
grid main
we will make a we will make a card here
in the app.css
so we can say grid
mean
in this function sorry in this class
name
we can say
display of grid
and all of these
fine we will have
this type of template so we don't need
the margin top
also let's try wait
user name username what is happening
remove template rows
refresh the page one second i think this
should be
let's make it
auto
auto
auto to auto adjust them
but wait something is wrong
here is
we have to make it a div here
let's try now now it's working
we have the name and the username
after the name
so let's make one border also
but we have to do it here in this day so
we can say div class name
grid
child
come to the app.css and say
grid
child here we can say
border
one pixel solid
two one two one two one
and we have a border here
let's add a little bit padding
10 pixels
not here
here
now they are
fine let me decrease the color it's
black let's make it
a little bit gray
grayer like
this will be fine
we can go more
okay okay okay this one should be fine
okay
we have the name and the username
fine
now what we have to do is what we have
to do
so we can see all the users
but let's create a search input first
so we can say input
placeholder should be
search
users
we will have the input of search wizards
a class name as well
of
search now let's come to about css and
search
then here we will be making
these things
also remove this border
we don't need that
okay it's too big so we can
make the height of 20 pixels
should be fine width to 80 percent
too much 50 let's try 40
okay 40 looks fine
then let's say margin top
and margin
of
margin top we need 20.
fine
also let's remove the outline
of this
to none
make it none
we have this
also change the border to
this color what is it
this
now we have this search we are giving
the power query
now let's get the query in a state so we
need one state as well so const
search
query
and set search
equals to use state it will be an empty
string empty string initially because
we don't need to search initially
so it's empty
then we can change
uncheck yes so on change event
let's type it here
on change event it will take
then we will use set search function to
set the query inside set the query
inside
let's search
event dot target dot value
save
whatever type in
this input will be stored inside the
search query
now comes the logic way to search
let's create a use effect hook here
simply like this
it will run when our state of
search query changes
like this
now let's try to
do this
what can we do
we will use filter on the user's array
filter function
filter
it will return a user to us
then
it will return us whatever condition we
write i mean it will return us only the
data according to the condition we write
here
not everything else
so it will filter them
so we can say users
first let's convert this object into an
array because we will use that function
plot
includes
that only works on arrays not objects
so object dot user sorry object.values
first convert it into an array like this
then join them
and it means to
make all the items in the array to be a
string using this join
fine
then we will convert all of the strings
that we have
like this lee and graham arden novel
into lower case
using two lower case method
so that we are having all the items in
lower case
then again
we need to use include our last
method here
so we will
find that if this search query
is included inside this whole string or
array string of arrays
it will return it
but what if we type something in
lowercase 30 not lowercase
in uppercase like this
in this case we have to use
to lowercase here as well to convert it
into lowercase
like this so make it to lowercase
and the logic is written
now what we have to do is we have to
create a state to set this data so we
can say const
let's say
searched
s-e-a-r-c-h searched
and
set searched equal to use state
this
then we will set it here
like
this
all the data i mean all the filtered
data will be stored inside the state
called searched
let's also create one more check
so if
this
query exists so what if it is empty
so if it contains something
we will set it all here
so cut and paste
else
we will
do this we will set users
to this
users just like that
fine
now what can we do
so we are showing
right now activate showing right now is
the original array
so
let me comment this out first
so if
this
not searched let's try this
search query
if the search for a dot length
is more than zero
we will return
the searched array
so
we can say
this
let's do this so searched
where is it
we can say search dot map
let's say search
then we will return some jsx which will
be
just nothing but this
so instead of this user we will use
search
and
so it's the first one let's do it in
second one
just return
this users dot map
or simply cut it
this
and now if we check let's try to search
something
try to search
l e a and and we will see the first one
if we cancel the search or clear the
search
it will go back to the original array
let's start search erwin hobble
erv so it's showing up here and we're
done
so that's how we create a search filter
in react using filter function
now let's try to
add one bonus feature here which is not
just any search debunked search
for example
let's say we type something here it's
searching one by one so it searches for
l first
then if you type e
it will set for l e which can be
inefficient
so now let's try to implement the bound
search
for example
if we type le it will not search
initially
or just
when we search it will search after one
second or two seconds
or depending on the
countdown we write
so in this if we can do
this
let's create a function called
searched equals to
this so in this this we will use
a
function called set timeout
so it will
create a timeout for us
and based on the timeout
this function will run
so the timeout is 1000 milliseconds
which is one second
so after the one second of typing here
we will get our results not
immediately
now we have to return
this and clean up do do clean up
so return
it
return
this so we can say clear timeout
and put the function inside which is
searched
now let's try to demo this search for l
e a
and after one second it will be here so
refresh the page
let's try once more
l e a
so you see after one second it's coming
here
clear it out
type l e
after one second the data will be here
so that's how we do the bound search in
react
make it 500 which will be 0.5 seconds or
half seconds
refresh it
type le
after 0.5 seconds this data will be here
in the filter data
after searching type lea
it will be here after 0.5 seconds
so that's how we implement the bound
search in react
so what is typescript first
type typescript is a superset of
javascript it means
typescript can do everything javascript
can but javascript cannot do everything
that script can
like the relation between css and scss
or sas
let me take an example of what can do we
do we type script additional things
see
we have this cons user which contains
first name last name and
role
but we are consoling the name here
so this will
cause an error on the compile time if it
is javascript
but in the type script we will get this
error called property name does not
exist on the type this and this
so let's try to duplicate this so let's
copy a paste it here
can remove all this code
so we have this user which contains
first name last name and role
but if we console the name which does
not exist here let's see what we get so
console
not log
name
but user dot name
user dot name
if we hover this name we will get the
same error that we are getting in the
chrome window property name does not
exist on the type
first time string last time string and
all
but if we add the first name it will not
throw an error because we already have
the first name here
so that is the power type script in
react
but how do we add typescript in react
so the basic
stuff is just open terminal
we need to do this
so if we are creating a react app
we usually do nbx create react app and
app name so let's make it app
but in case of type script if you want
to add it in react app we use the flag
called template
and the name which is typescript
if you've seen the documentation of
create react app you will see the same
thing here
template and the
typescript we will get not js files but
tsx file tsx which stands for typescript
in jsx
so
and one more file we get is this file
called ts config.json
which determines how are we going to
compile our code to type script
from
javascript because this browser does not
does not understand the typescript code
it needs to get compiled to javascript
so that's what
how do we create a test script app in
react
so let me rewind it once more
what is javascript typescript is nothing
but a superset of javascript it means
everything javascript can do
typescript can do
and more but everything that script can
do javascript cannot
fine
it has so many features like type
checking interfaces and all you see all
these things here error handling
no interference windings in javascript
but in typescript we have the editor
warning
if you make it a name it will throw an
error that name does not exist in this
user
object
like this
so that is the benefit of using
typescript
for example let's say we have a state
here of count
and set count tested
the value is 0 initially
and we are putting the count value here
and a button to increment the count so
basically we will test
these two things that the count value is
0 or not initially
and this button
when clicked is incrementing this count
or not
using this library called
react testing library
which is default
in the
create react app it comes with a package
you don't have to install it externally
but if you want to
install it just use the command or just
go to
react testing library
this first one
then you have to install using this
command and install
save diff react testing library or
testing library react
so now let's start
to test these apps
not this app this operation yes
so the first step here is to do
something like this
we have this file called app.test.js
so let me create one component here
that will be
called
dot js
a file let me move all of these things
like count and button click
here make it a functional component
first
then let me move it here
like this
also we need to
[Music]
transfer the state
count here
and import the state
i mean the use statement use state
now let me
import this component called count here
so import count sorry counter
from counter
then simply render it here like this
it will still run fine we can increment
the count as we want so for app.js we
have a file called app.test.js but let's
say
we have a counter
component we want to test it for this
component
we will create a file the same way we
have app.test.js we will name it
counter dot
test
dot js
you can name it anything you want but
let's go with this counter test.js
and if you open up
app.js you will see
these things render and screen
that we need to import we also need to
import the component like app
so here let me import these two things
let me remove screen for now we don't
need it
and this app will become
counter
from
one step back counter
save
next thing we need is to use this test
keyword
so test means we are going to test
something
so let's do it
we will write a test here a unit test
in which we will run a description first
so here it says renders
learn react link but we will
write something like
check the
initial
value of
increment sorry in not increment
count
then we have to use the callback
function
just like this
let me write a callback here
here
we will write this render so render
means we will render this app component
but in place of app we will render this
counter
like this
so now this counter will return
something
so we can say const
const
and object
this equal to this we have to
destructure
the object here
from this render
one more thing
if you come to this counter so we are
just calculating the
value of count initially so we have to
pass
an initial value here so initial
value
equals to something
so let's say we have to pass 0
only when it will succeed
because if we check this counter.js
the value is 0 initially this value so
we have to check our test case against
this
and same here we have to do so pass it
save at both places
now
as i said this
render will return something
and this will be
this counter value this current value
inside this h1 because let's say we
change the count
this will be changed as well
so we need to pass or we need to assign
a prop here which is called
data
test
id
i think that's it
and we can say
count
and here we have to
make or we have to grab this id using
this function called
get
by test id
i think that's it
so now furthermore we have to grab our
value of this count
from this test get by test id we will do
let
create a variable called
counter equals to
this thing which is
get by test id
and it contains our id
which is count so we have to pass count
here i mean it contains our value
so we have to pass count to filter that
value
of this count which is zero
now we will
we have the counter value but we have to
make or get the text from there
so we will use a function called or a
prop called
uh
text content yes this
now this counter contains our
value of the account initial value 0.
now
but the problem is it's not a number
it's a string
so when we run the
test script it will fail
now we will use our thing called expect
expect means
what value we're expecting
so we're expecting
this count to be something
which is
equal to
or equal to equal sorry
uh to equal zero
yes
by the way we we should have counter red
dot count
and our script is written successfully
now let's try to run it and see what
happens
open the new terminal
and here we will simply type
npm test
we are testing i mean we are writing
this nbm test because open the
package.json file
you will see in the scripts
we have
npm start to start the app similarly we
have the test
or npm test to test the app
press enter
it will test your application or mainly
run the script
let me
zoom this
or
make it in the whole page so it's
running the test
the problem is we also have on test in
app.test.js
it will throw an error so we can delete
it later
see it will fail because here it's not
getting
this let me show you
it's not getting all of these
here
where is the m.js
this it's not getting all of these so
let me remove
test from app
so delete it simply
delete this file
then in the setup tests okay we have to
import this
report web vitals index.js
where do we import tests
we have a vitals i think that's all
now let's test it again
clear this let me clear this
and try again
npm test
let's see
what we get
so it's running now the first or only
the one test that we have
it's running it
and it will fail
because see expected is zero
but we received
the zero in quotes it means it's a
string
so it will not work here like this
we have to wrap or we have to make
this value
or this value in a number or a numeric
value
so let's do it so just wrap
this counter into a number to make a
number
not a string
let me clear this once more
or i think that is automatic
so it's running the test now
this should
be
successful
it's a basic test to show you how do we
do this
so it's running now it's passed
check the initial value of the count
it's passed in 30 milliseconds
or what is this point
and time is this
it has been passed so it means
that our test has been passed and
the value of count here
is the way zero
it means this has been passed okay
now let's write one more test to check
the increment
functionality
so we will copy this test
once more then we will have
check the
increment
button
we have writers wrote this description
and similarly like this gate is by ida
function we will call one function
called
get by role
so you see this button has a role
it's a trigger event so it's the role
that's why we are using this function
let's create an instance of this
button so let's say increment
btn equals to
get by role
we will pass
the
role which is
the button
like this
and the
title
i think that's right but
yes button and the name
so the name is
this increment
let me check here
increment count is the name we have to
grab the button from here like this
so we are having this
tape
now we need a function to trigger this
button from here
which is called
uh fire event i think yes this one
we have to pass this fire sorry we have
to pass
this increment button
in this fire event
on click function so click
when this fire event is clicked
it will run this encryption button
and all of these things
so now this
fire event
or this test case
should expect something just like we did
it here it expected this counter to be
equal to zero
initial counter
but in this case
it will be expected to be the same c the
problem here is
we are incrementing the count here to 0
but we are taking it here so it's
already 0 and we are passing 0 here so
it will pass
this test case
if we go to this test case and see
two cases passed
so if we make it as 1
it will fail because
we are sending
something else but we are expecting
something else
it will be here soon see
expected was 1 but it received 0. so it
failed
so what we have to do is we have to make
this zero
and put it here
so basically
counter is checking for zero it will be
0 then it will run
true because both are 0
then it will it will run this increment
button feature or test
and fire it it will fire the event
then let's create one more counter which
will be
counter
inc which is mean which means counter
increment
then we can expect
the one value after increment so input
will be clicked then it will be one not
zero
now save and pass this counter rank here
say when let's test what we get
this test should pass
or it will pass
i'm waiting yes
both passed
i mean both twists
if you make this a zero it will fail
because
it was the row then the button clicked
again it's still 0
we are passing here so it will fail
it's expecting 1 not 0
see
it failed
so that was
how we test a app in react or how we
test our
components in react using this testing
library from react
so basically i am calling an api here
from this
where this
website
and i am storing the data in the state
called data state
and we are mapping and all
if the api is loading we will see
loading text
and if it is loaded we will see the data
now let me make or let me just refresh
the page first
you will see what i mean
you will see the loading text for a
moment and then it disappears and then
the data is coming
but let's make the network request
little bit slower
so we will do it like this how do we do
this
slow 3g
now refresh
the page it's refreshing
and we will see the loading text for
some time and then the actual data that
we need
then we refresh again or let's say we've
changed some pages
this api call will be same it will call
the api once more
so to avoid that let's use
this react query library to cache the
api calls
first of all we will install two
libraries there which is react router
and this react query so add this wait a
second
this and react
query
so this react router will be used to
navigate building pages
and this query react will be used to
like
cache our api call fetch and cache
so is this it the command which is npmi
react query let me check
where is the command
installation
yes it's the same
press enter it will install this both
libraries in our reactor and let's wait
for it
so they have been installed and setup is
also done
setup is nothing but two routes
normal call page and cached call page
if we go to the cached call we will see
the cached call text if we go to normal
call we will see the loading text and
the data after that
go to cache call again
come to normal call and it's loading
again that's why we are going to cache
this api so that
if the data is the same it will not load
again it will get it from the cache
and for this we are going to use react
query here
this library so let's do it
to set up this react query in our react
app
we need to import
a thing called or two things called
react query client provider and
just the react query client
so import
this from react query
we will say
uh query
client and
query client provider
then we need to wrap
this div into this query client provider
like this
save
and this will take a key called client
and we have to pass this instance of
this client so let's create an instance
to create an instance we can just say
let
query
client
ent equals to
let's say
query client
and then pass it here
save
and our app will load
but it's not loading
because
i don't know because why
because i have missed one keyword here
it's called new
that's how we create an instance
so now save it
and it will be fine
so it's done
the basic setup of react query now we
have to
call this api again in cached call
so let's do it
and in this component let's import a
thing called use very from react query
so we can say import
from
react query
we will use something called
what i said just
right now you is use query like this
so it will be a function that we need
so we have imported it
and then we have to do
this
so
copy this us query
and here let me create
the use query function like this
so it takes a query
a key
so the key could be anything you want
but let me make it as
data or yes data
then second thing it takes wait a second
yes data one parenthesis we need then
second thing it takes is a callback
function like this
and in this callback function we will do
the
api call
so this api call is here so let me get
this
and paste it
save it
and it's doing all the same all the
things
that it was doing before in the normal
call.js
now let's create the states here
whatever we had in the normal call
data and loading states so copyist and
paste it here
save
now import the state or the use
statement from react
because we need to import it like this
fine
the next thing we need is to do is
we have to map this api from this data
just like we did in the normal call so
we can just copy and paste it here
after the cached call
and save
so instead of the data
i mean instead of this normal api call
in this user effect book we are calling
it in the
us query hook from react query
also let me set up this loading text
so if loading is true i will see loading
or else we will see the result
that's fine
but as of right now the both pages are
same the api calls
click cached call
we'll see loading
click normal call you will still see the
loading text even if the data is not
changing from this api
so what we have to do is to fix this or
to manage this remove this then block
and return this whole thing
using return keyword
then we will cache it in a response or
run in a variable so say const
let's say it is that
equals to this
and we don't need these two as well
because we will structure it from this
result
directly
so if we console
this result
you will get sorry not data result we
will get the loading and the cached
i am in the loading in the data so
just command this and loading is not
defined
command this as well
now open the console and let's check
we are seeing all these things from this
query which is
data that we need
we need the error if we have an error we
will get the error here
we can restructure it from this result
is faced
it is true because data has been fetched
it is error is error because no edits we
have
is fetched after mount yes
is fetching false
it means
if the data is still switching this will
be true
it is loading error so we have all of
these things
so we need loading
so let me structure the data and loading
from this result
so we can say
data and
loading
not loading is loading
yes because it's false
and
if we comment or bring it back
make the loading as is loading
and
bring back this thing
we can
have a result it's not defined okay
result is not defined yes this one
now it will work fine
we will have the cached call properly
called
so
now let's start from the start refresh
the page once
the cache file is here
click normal call
you will see loading text
now click cast call again we will not
see
the loading text because
the data is not changing
it will simply call the api i will not
call the api
it will cache the api that you already
did and it's displaying as the results
we need to remove the state use network
save
and
click normal call
we will see loading text
click cached call we will not see the
loading text
so now let me make it a little bit
slower
i mean the network
make it as
okay it's much slower okay
now clear the console or clear the
invert tab
now click cached call
so i did not click the normal call
loading is here
it's loading
and now the data is there but if we
click cached call we will not see
loading because it has been cached
see directly getting the results without
loading text
or loading h1
so that's how we catch an api in react
using this react query